monkey snake
oh yeah baby supreme court decision is
in
and here i am right
right in the nick of time right woo
oh
are you excited i have pop well yes i'm
as excited as i can be uh for feeling
like i've just serviced the device from
seven
well i have strep
but there's bigger news than i have
strep there's bigger news than that and
you know why i have strep it's a
beautiful thing because my son went
and then punched his fist into my mouth
and i said i'm gonna get sick
and so i think it's viral and then strip
is bacterial i don't know but it's
developed into something and the reason
i say that's beautiful is because hey
you know what
in a lot of states
my son my twins could have been aborted
up until the moment they actually up
until the moment they were born because
they were born early yeah twins often
are
and seeing their face seeing that
ultrasound
seeing what they're becoming they're
about to come up on their first birthday
um
there's no denying this to life
so let me spit out this
and just this is going to be gross for
you guys but
that's not even the argument anymore it
hasn't been the argument for a while
before i get into this um we do have the
promo code save scotus
mugclub.com
uh sorry letter with credit.com mug club
i'm excited i'm excited we're very
excited because this just came down and
we do have our people on the ground on
locations we'll be going down to uh
washington dc
with gingersnap
roe v wade
right now in this case
has officially been overturned
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it doesn't seem like enough considering
the millions upon millions of lives that
have been lost that will now be
potentially safe and by the way this
just means for people who are freaking
out this just means
that
the laws can go back to the states that
the restrictions they were not allowed
to place on abortions beforehand
are now going to be permitted like like
a heartbeat bill right exactly where it
should have been in the first place and
that's the ruling that we see today is
basically that it was wrong to begin
with so let me lead marley was dead to
begin with the ruling here this is taken
straight
from the ruling page five it says
we hold that row and casey must be
overruled the constitution makes no
reference to abortion yep boom
and no such right is implicitly
protected by any constitutional
provision including the one on which the
defenders of roe and casey now chiefly
rely the due process clause of the 14th
amendment for people who don't remember
we have a card right here if you're
watching on youtube and it's archived it
was basically a right to privacy clause
which some people argue isn't
necessarily a right either
and that's a whole different discussion
but that is
the basis
for roe v wade there is no
constitutional right to an abortion
unlike the constitutional right to
both keep and bear arms we'll get into
that
specifically spelled out
uh okay now chiefly rely the due process
clause of the 14th amendment that
provision has been held to guarantee
some rights that are not mentioned in
the constitution but any such right must
be deeply rooted in this nation's
history and tradition and quote implicit
in the concept of ordered liberty
the right to abortion does not fall
within this category until the latter
part of the 20th century such a right
was entirely unknown in american law
indeed when the 14th amendment was
adopted three quarters of the states
made abortion a crime at all stages
of pregnancy
the abortion right is also critically
different from any other right that this
court has held to fall within the 14th
amendment protection of quote liberty
rose defenders characterize the abortion
rights
as similar to the rights recognized in
the past decisions involving matters
such as intimate sexual relations
contraception or marriage but abortion
is fundamentally different as both row
and casey acknowledge that's pivotal
that's pivotal it's saying look who's oh
what about what about uh contraception
what about no no hold on a second if you
look at the case case law matters with
roe
v wade and you look at casey
these
the these these cases that were brought
forward right these suits they
acknowledge that abortion was different
they never started this with saying
abortion was just you know treating a
child as a nuisance or medical condition
that's very new so a lot of the the
opinions that are being expressed right
now that you'll see on cnn and that no
doubt will lead to violence keep your
head in a swivel churches please protect
your flock i do not mean go out and be
vigilantes what i'm saying is protect
your flock crisis pregnancy centers we
have a lot of good people good friends
good family members who work there make
sure that you are safe yeah catholic
church is battening down the hatches
essentially right now they're planning
for people to be mobbing their churches
to be graffiti to do more than that to
firebomb also jane's revenge just called
on people to have like a day of rage
actually we're calling for it before the
decision anticipating that it would be
like the leaked document right right so
night of rage or day of rage whatever it
is
it's it's going to be a crazy weekend
and that'll just be a day of a day of
nagging and whining until the men show
up well and running out of breath
abortion is fundamentally different as
roe and casey acknowledge because it
destroys what those decisions called
quote fetal life and what the law now
before us describes as quote an unborn
human being so this is important look
the ruling here and it's very similar to
the ruling yesterday on the kerry law in
new york it's based on constitutionality
and it's telling us that even the
arguments the left has made now we know
culturally it was safe legal and rare to
now on-demand taxpayer-funded period
yeah right no vagina no choice no uterus
no choice and then it changed to uh no
uterus no choice one transgender
menstruating person's have the choice we
just we can't keep track of it so we
know culturally the arguments have
changed but legally the terminoli the
terminology has changed again that
matters precedence matters
called fetal life
those decisions this just because it
destroys what those decisions called
fetal life and what the law now before
us
describes as an unborn human being
meaning that it's different
meaning that back in the day when we're
talking about roe v wade
you know they still try to argue well
it's not a life because it's not viable
but when you see the shrieking and the
protests that go on because of
states that put laws into place where
it's no longer an issue it's no longer
deniable that it's a life
whether viable or not in some cases yes
viable
that's changed and so the court has said
we now have to make sure that we
recognize this change as it's codified
into law this had to happen there was no
way for it not to happen and leftists
you have no one to blame but yourself
yeah you have no one to blame but
yourself you went from safe legal and
rare to you know within a few weeks
after uh after pregnancy which i don't
agree with but guess what you had a lot
of people on your side two all the way
up until and including nine months even
birth period and we see that in certain
states it's your fault it's your fault
that your guy
has the lowest approval rating of any
modern president it's your fault that
people are now going to vote against you
on mass including latinos including
people under the age of 30 including
black people
it's your fault that the court said
we've got to do something about this roe
v wade [ __ ]
even jews justice ruth bader ginsburg
said it was bad law and it was doomed to
fail for this reason yeah
absolutely well and i think too what you
said is that it just goes back to the
states this is what you want the supreme
court to do you want them to look at the
constitution and say is there a right
that is recognized by this constitution
that is being infringed upon or are we
trying to create something brand new
nothing was being infringed upon by
saying hey a state has to write the
right to make abortion illegal at a
certain point and states had different
laws
across this country had a lot of
different laws right now states will
still have different laws california and
new york will be advertising fly here
for an abortion vacation i guarantee you
you'll see those exact words at some
point probably in colorado too there
will be there will be a shrooms and
abortion deal yeah absolutely and and
basically
is the ability to come and kill an
unborn child right something that is
different and the court just said look
we don't have any say on this the state
has a say on this that's what you want
you don't want the supreme court making
laws you don't want the supreme court
fabricating things out of thin air
that's what congress is for they are the
elected representatives of the people
the court is not elected they just
interpret and guys let me know get me
more of the bill when you can i don't
know if you want to put it in the show
map uh at the top there and let me know
when gingersnap is ready by the way
gingersnap our on the ground reporter
was in front of cnn's cameras so
multiple times hopefully we'll be able
to get him to broadcast in front of
cnn's camera since they're okay with all
the disruptors there right now maybe
they'll be okay with our disrupter but
it's just very important to contrast
yesterday you know new york had a
conceal didn't allow people to carry
firearms and that's worked like a charm
in new york now the reaction to that
which is a constitutional right so in
this case it said this is a
constitutional right and this is very
easy for people who don't know this is
remedial what is not a state issue is it
in the constitution the bill of rights
right that's something you cannot affect
in the states
the right to keep and bear arms is there
period
just like the right to speak is there
period and they said states cannot
infringe on your constitutional right
this is a constitutional issue the left
freaked out so we need to dissolve the
supreme court now today contrast it with
abortion
excuse me again like i said i am very
sick
where they say hold on a second there is
no constitutional right to an abortion
so we're going to leave that to the
states
both of these if you're going to talk
about middle ground both of these are
very moderate decisions it's well this
isn't the constitution so the states
can't infringe upon it this isn't in the
constitution so states have the right to
create their own laws they're not saying
that new york
as far as i i haven't had time to read
the full bill it came down five minutes
ago as sorry as the full ruling they're
not saying that new york can't allow
abortion up until
eight months or colorado up until 30
plus weeks they're not saying that here
they're just saying that texas can put
in a law that says that a heartbeat yeah
and you may not like it but it's not
your body if you're ending another
heartbeat you don't have two hearts
you're not a trout
but it's also well many of these uh
broads over here no doubt smell like
they just came from a long day working
at the fish hatchery
hey we're good to go with lane he's
already been on cnn and nbc as well wow
okay really so let's go live and as you
guys pull more from the bill then i want
to talk about yesterday's bill and
contrasting it and why we predict
violence unfortunately and unrest this
weekend it's time to go on locations go
to swatch with gingersnap
[Music]
all right gingersnap
uh can you put them up there tool man um
hopefully you're yeah it looks like we
have a better connection than yesterday
have you been uh have you been doing
same shirt though so i guess you just
packed in overnight
no no it's just my different hawaiian
shirt you know i want to mix it up a
little bit but um yeah right when it
dropped the pro-life crowd went crazy
and then the immediately the
pro-abortion crowd started chanting
illegitimate take to the streets we had
people coming up with uh antiques to get
up saying who do you work for um
capital hopefully there's tons of police
way more than yesterday
it's pretty wild out here um this is the
pro-life people right here and then the
people are over here they're kind of
quiet now it seems like they're
dissipating i don't know what they're
doing but there's a lot of calls to take
to the streets you know
what by whatever means necessary
overturn illegitimate you know all the
catchphrases that the liberals love to
shout i mean they're shouting them and
they were playing rage against the
machine for a little bit so i knew that
would make you really happy oh yeah
cause tom morello is a piece of [ __ ]
yeah so he rages against the machine by
wanting to increase the size of the
machine
yeah and well the machine got a little
bit smaller today and they don't seem to
be too happy about it hey you know what
also a good way to ensure the machine
doesn't grow and you can rage against it
being allowed to keep your guns i think
if you move to your right a little bit
you will get in the cnn shot and we can
show
the lie snap ginger snap there's a giant
black man in a red shirt ghost yeah
there's a giant there he is right there
go stand right in front you know go talk
to him go talk yeah talk to that they're
holding oh they just move it stick right
around there stick just loiter right
around there because they're on cnn but
right now it's an aveeno commercial yeah
so you are right in the mix there um is
this man security this this large
african-american in a red shirt
[Music]
okay good good for yeah he seems like
he's there being pretty peaceful
what are they chanting right now
rise up for abortion rights rise up it's
very creative
yeah rise up for abortion it's kind of
it's a it's got a rhythm to it right
well i don't know how you rise up for
abortion you have to sit in stirrups
well
that's a fair point
yeah
it should be lay prone for abortion
[Applause]
what are they chanting their gingersnap
the whole the whole world is watching
that's true
hey by the way the whole world is
watching and including european laws
that are far more restrictive on
abortions that people don't quite
understand we have the loosest abortion
laws in the country outside of canada
even people in europe don't understand
that
right and like you were saying earlier
it's not gonna it's not illegalizing
abortion across the country nobody here
gets that like as much as they're
protesting nobody understands what the
decision means right
have you talked with people there have
you talked with the pro-abortion
activists and and gotten a feel for what
they understand or what they think this
ruling is
like a good portion of them think that
nobody can get abortions anywhere ever
um some are a little more well-versed
than others but generally people kind of
don't know what's going on they think no
one's gonna get an abortion ever again
okay uh gingersnap we'll go back to you
stay in that general stay in that
general area to keep in mind kind of
where the cnn camera is you right now
and then once they come back i want to
show them live with you but just stay in
that area see if you can see uh speak
with some people but stay in that
general area because uh you're gonna be
on cnn's camera and then maybe we can
have you doing jumping jacks on cnn
that'll be your moment yeah
yeah yeah see what he has to say all
right we'll go back to uh junior snap
you can just uh bring him down uh bring
him down low but kind of keep him on
standby i think that was the same guy
from yesterday we were like wow that's
that guy off camera left is jacked i
think it's the same guy right yeah
someone mute my mic really quickly
because i'm gonna blow my nose this is
very disgusting right now but we do this
for you stephen had to run into the
studio and get everybody going this
morning because we thought this was
gonna drop i'm so glad it did because
any more time on this
just would lead to worse situations now
dropping on the weekend bad idea that's
a rough deal hey and can you guys pull
up uh guys pull up there in the control
room uh some of the uh some of the uh
the tweets and some of the calls to
violence that we already see going on
should have been on wednesday like do it
on a wednesday no not the cost of
violence
of course no violence is fine on
wednesday apparently just not on
thursday friday saturday right right
well here's the thing is
they try to say that the donald trump
doesn't believe in rule of law that
republicans don't believe in rule of law
and when they don't like the rules of
the game they change them they want to
pack the court and it gets worse than
that by the way you have let's bring
this up overlay hey keith oberman for
example yeah and he's not an outlier
called for what i think is sedition he
said it has been it has become necessary
to dissolve the supreme court of the
united states this is after the gun
ruling yeah uh the concealed carry
ruling the first step is for a state
the court has now forced guns upon to
ignore this ruling great you're a court
why and how do you think you can enforce
your rulings ignore
the court what um yeah
okay so in other words let's take the
most extreme example let's take the
january 6 you know worse than 911
horrible domestic terrorists who are
saying hey we want to re-examine the
election right we don't want to certify
it right now they weren't saying
overturn it at that point they were
saying we think we need to wait to
certify because we have a lot of
unanswered questions this is not a wait
and find out this is a this is ignore
one of the three branches of government
yeah which by the way is an important
check and balance because they are not
elected
that's important to note
how is that not sedition and by the way
this is not just him so you have him
saying we're just going to ignore the
court yeah this is what happened
yesterday and we'll get to what's
happening today as it unfolds um
new york and california both propose
basically just workarounds to ensure
that your constitutional rights just
recognized by the supreme court to carry
firearms
will not be recognized in their state so
right here we have i think it's new york
ag proposing workarounds for the
concealed carry law let's watch that in
light of today's ruling by the united
states supreme court in this case
we cannot
idly stand by and just watch our streets
be flooded with guns due to more people
being permitted to legally carry
firearms in public our proposed solution
encourages the state to tailor a law
that accounts for new york city's high
population density as a factor in
establishing specific parameters for the
designation of sensitive areas
where legal firearms are prohibited from
being carried by members of the public
sensitive hair areas like your
hairdresser okay let's um they'll just
declare anything a sensitive area too
that's the thing sidewalk sensitive area
your car a sensitive area yeah public
street sensitive area grocery stores
sensitive area right we have so many
people that's your defense yeah we have
population density would that mean
there's potential for crime there's more
opportunity for people to come up and
accost you on the street rob beat
whatever all right let's go back to
gingersnap because cnn let's bring up
let's have gingersnap and cnn um
gingersnap can you hear me sir yeah yeah
i'm good all right so gingersnap again
right on cnn the uh the african-american
gentleman in the red shirt he's there
and if you walk a little fur so if you
walk a little walk right next to him and
then walk a little closer
sorry further away
from the steps there
um you'll be getting so now now turn to
your left
turn to your left
and walk forward
and i think we're going to see you here
on cnn walk forward walk forward walk
forward
i don't see him there do you see him
there yet no let's see hold on a second
are you right next to the
african-american gentleman
yeah just follow him because he's right
in front of cnn and then get in then get
in in front of him
are you talking about the red shirt guys
yes the retro guy yeah no they they took
off you know the retro guy's right there
he's right there he's right there i see
him
he's moving away now but there you are i
see him turn to your right
to your right gingersnap
this is my right that is not your right
your back is to the camera of cnn just
turn around
great now turn around and now let's
bring it up let's bring up ginger snap
start doing jumping jacks jumping as
high as you can jumping jacks for life
that must be delayed just a little bit
jumping jacks for life
jumping jacks for life for life jumping
jacks for life as high as you can do
them big arms like you're waiting for
i'm a white person i can't jump that
high but come on now you played sports
oh we see you right there on cnn yeah
there you go delayed that's why there
was a little bit of a yeah there's a bit
of a delay because they're afraid that
conservatives might start doing jumping
jacks you know as opposed to burning
down cities oh yeah there he is i see
him right yeah above the w i need to do
some calisthenics in celebration i don't
really want to burn down anything well
this is this is wonderful and uh it
would be great if you could walk right
up to the cnn's
put him on cnn put him on cnn there you
are there is jumping jacks there you go
there you go
jumping jacks for life baby so now if
you've been jacked for life if you can
find your so uh if you can find the cnn
camera again it's further away from i'm
trying to see it's a small monitor are
they from the supreme court about this
i'll describe it so in the in the middle
of the supreme court they are directly
centered on the supreme court pillars
straight back right so they're behind
where you were just a little bit and
basically
dead center on the supreme court maybe
just a hair offset to the right that's
their camera the black guy in the red
shirt right now on cnn they're the
supreme court's kind of seven o'clock
yeah
so if you get there then we can just
then we can just talk with you and they
can watch us here what broadcast with
you on cnn and we get free advertising
yeah the right i got it
yeah if you stand right next to the guy
in the red yeah but
it's like a 10 second 15 second delay it
seems so yeah
but the guy in the red is consistently
close to cnn camera he might be trying
to he might be trying to steal a little
bit of your shine in your snap he's got
like an instagram page so he's trying to
just get some more yeah he's right there
he's right there it's a 30-second delay
it's a 30-second delay so
you should be pretty close so he's been
standing there for more than 30 seconds
so
i'm probably i'm probably three seconds
away or three steps yeah we can see he's
walking up
if you can stand right behind him i
think that's the best camera yeah angle
oh yeah
yeah i think you're being obscured by
him right now yeah
if you can step to your right gingersnap
just a little bit you should be able to
see the camera you know what there you
go so step to your right a little bit
step to your right a little bit and come
forward a few steps so step to your
right because you're being covered by
the uh oh there you go there he is yep
it's almost like where's waldo right and
then walk forward a little bit
okay
start doing you know what start doing
some jumping jacks flip the bird to the
camera at cnn flip the bird to the
camera give him the middle finger for
life
um
i would rather not do that
i will do
some jumping jacks there you
jumping go just say jumping jacks for
life just yell out jumping jacks for
life and do them we're doing jumping
jacks for life jumping go go but you got
to do gotta jump come on come on you're
happy lives are being saved gingersnap
i don't care you have to do it you have
to delete it
you're the hero you're the hero these
people need not the one they deserve
neither i'm probably neither to be
honest with you crying out loud
[Laughter]
so you are on cnn
there you go yeah baby okay wonderful
wonderful you're right there stay right
there you're beautiful you're right in
front of cnn right now so stay right
where you are i love it uh put him on
here joking on uh sorry on here uh tool
man so what else is happening what are
they yelling do you feel it escalating
at all there ginger snap
he's spreading the jumping jacks for a
lot yeah
what are they yelling what are those
what are those cackling witches yelling
abortion on demand oh there you go we'll
see that's
that's exactly why this ruling came down
because it's not about safe legal and
rare they want all abortions up until
nine months on demand and they're still
there yelling it
yeah
yeah it was never about safe legal ever
ever ever it just now the facade's gone
that's it can you can you try and talk
with one and see i see that reporter
behind you but try and talk about and
see uh ask them what they expect to do
this weekend what you know what what
what they expect to happen do they
expect protests do they expect marches
there's a lady behind you with that
bandana hey can he do it like this what
do we do next yeah what do we do next
ask them what do we do next
from us yeah
what do we do next how do we how do we
fight this what do we do next
we do legal abortion on demand i guess
that's how he that's what we do okay
what about that guy right there with the
uh holding the bandana over him maybe
you can ask him
he's talking to univision right now so i
think they're doing spanish language
interviews i don't know if i'm gonna be
much help there oh yeah because those
those um those uh telemundo viewers
they're really pro-abortion those types
yeah those mexican catholics
it's in the catholic bible yeah it's
just before genesis yes yeah yeah yeah
what we are watching what we are
watching right now people live and again
it's safe scotus is the promo code we
are watching is the left turn off yet
another demographic of voters
all that's required right now is
education right we're going to read more
of this bill guys get it to me and uh
all that's required is for them to see
the protest for them to see the riots
and for us to say hey why do you think
they're writing and they'll say well
because you know they think abortion is
being banned and you explain to them
it's not being banned and these people
are protesting they're writing because
they want abortions all the way up until
including nine months period without the
states having the rights to restrict
them when you communicate that to black
americans as you saw when i just did the
uh talking with people segment when you
communicate that to
latino americans hispanic americans when
you communicate that to nearly all
demographics of americans they say oh
well that's unreasonable right we need
to make sure that this message is
communicated that this is just about
giving the states the right
to ensure
uh that they can regulate abortions so
they don't have to be in new york
colorado or california where you can
have an abortion all the way up until
and through the third trimester yeah and
most americans agree that the states
should have the right to make their own
laws i understand people that would be
on the left that say well then that's
going to make it oppressive for women
that live in texas to be able to get out
of the state if you're in a large state
you're not close to a border with a
state that you can go get an abortion in
right but my argument back would be like
okay well let's say that that's true
let's just say that it is going to be
more difficult for people to get an
abortion now maybe what we do is try to
prevent the pregnancy in the first place
can we all agree that maybe that's
probably the place to start now and
there are a lot of different ways to do
it right can we just do that first
instead of saying hey let's just kill
the child oh hold on a second uh uh
junior snapper speaking with some people
let's listen in okay
what do we do like obviously they
overturned it what is left for us to do
it's so scary
do you think anything's gonna happen in
the more immediate future like
very very slow it takes a long time to
make change
right but what about like this weekend
tonight do you think dc is getting like
is anything gonna happen dc or is it
i don't know there's not a whole lot of
people doing that okay what do you mean
yeah
i think more people will show up
throughout the day but people are at
work i don't know okay
all right well what what
let me ask him this ask him this
abortion in dc
so right now we have this on twitter we
have uh this is from the from angry
black lady it says rowan casey are
overruled in a 6-3 decision
time to get to work and there's a meme
with a uh a finger pistol so a meme
there showing you know some kind of
violence implying uh using a gun blue
check by the way blue check mark ask him
what he thinks about that a blue
checkmark blue check marks on twitter uh
alluding to using guns and violence
so what do you say like what would you
say to the people
oh are we losing them
ah we are all right we'll go back to him
later oh
come on you can take him
let's go back to gender snap later let's
continue reading here uh some of the the
law uh right here you have albert
foxconn who's an nyu law professor he
says this is how democracy dies
not with a bang but with legalese if
you're a professor of law how do you not
understand this how do you not portray
this in an accurate way like hey guys i
understand that everybody's freaking out
right now and you want to be able to
have abortion and i get it you know my
body my choice i'm on your side this is
what he's saying
all this does is kick it back to new
york you're in new york new york's not
going to change their laws related to
abortion right by the way we also have
multiple tentacles into some of these
leftist groups uh online so you guys are
in control and you know what to do let
us know what they're discussing
especially they can help keep people
safe
my life has been saved on multiple
occasions from that just kind of keeping
tabs on them so this is from the
decision right now i'm just going to
read you going to read you a little bit
more
um stare decisis the doctrine on which
casey's controlling opinion was based
does not compel unending adherence to
rose abuse of judicial authority roe was
egregiously wrong from the start its
reasoning was exceptionally weak and the
decision has had damaging consequences
and far from
far from bringing about a national
settlement of the abortion issue row and
casey have inflamed debate and deepened
division you think yeah it is time to
heed the constitution and return the
issue of abortion to the people's
elected representatives the
permissibility of abortion and the
imitations let me just hit that real
quick because you just look at the nyu
law professor saying this is how
democracy dies this is what the left
means when they say democracy they mean
mob rule and exactly what they want
because just read this this is pivotal
from the decision
it is time to heed the constitution and
return the issue of abortion to the
people's elected representatives so what
is the supreme court saying here they
are saying hey
we shouldn't be the ones in charge of
this it should be the people's elected
representatives in their state
that's how democracy dies by giving by
removing power by recusing yourself as
supreme court justices
and giving that power to elected
representatives according to the bill
what is democracy
you know in other words their issue here
is not that the supreme court has taken
more power their issue here is that the
supreme court has not with an iron fist
ruled in an authoritarian fashion that
abortion is to be allowed on demand
taxpayer funded up until birth including
pre
up until the end of pregnancy including
birth period by the way that is what
their platform is that is what the dnc
platform is these aren't extreme fringe
activists look at joe biden look at
kamala harris look at elizabeth warren
look at bernie sanders
not one
not one
was ever willing to say when
restrictions should be placed on
abortions not one so here's the issue
when they have a problem with supreme
court justices
they have a problem with conservative
supreme court justices originalists they
have a problem with these justices
consistently saying
that
we don't have this authority right what
was the ruling yesterday the
constitution gives you the right we
don't have this authority they say
they're thrusting guns upon us
no they're not
no they're not
they're saying hey look abortion this
was bad law we don't have the authority
to say that people's elected
representatives can't create laws
regarding restricting abortions we are
going to return the issue of abortion to
people's elected representatives to
which nyu law professors you just saw
now live say this is how democracy dies
democracy dies by the unelected judicial
branch
giving more power to the elected
representatives of people's direct
states and communities yeah what's
democracy can you guys comment below
let's define democracy and thank god
we're a representative republic a
constitutional republic
but this is the court literally giving
more power
to you democratically in your state
what they really mean is this is how
democracy dies because i didn't get
exactly what i want yeah exactly and i
want to make sure that everybody
understands that when we have riots
which we will have depending on the size
and the scope of the riots in different
cities across the country we'll have
them are we going to go back to these
comments like we did with donald trump
and say see they were inciting violence
here this is how democracy dies when you
put it like that when you start to tell
people that the democracy is dying and
really what's happening is the power is
going back to the states you're telling
them that now is the time to fight now
is the time that if you don't take to
the streets you won't have a country
again donald trump was making comments
because he believed whether you agree
with him or not that he was defrauded
and that democracy had been stolen
and that's what he was talking about at
least if he had been right that would
have been true in this case if they're
right and and roe has been overturned
it's not true that democracy is
infringed upon at all it just goes back
to the states there is no place there is
no argument to say that this is a a hit
against democracy there is none
whatsoever and very very little will
change in regards to abortion law
outside of places like mississippi and
texas can now say hey done there's
another heartbeat i want to i want to
end it though [ __ ] it's not your
heartbeat them's the breaks and then to
cry about it and then in new york as
perverse as it is they can say hey yeah
you can terminate it you have 20 fingers
20 toes two hearts two brains
you have 20 sets of fingernails toenails
you as one human have two different sets
of dna genetic code you can kill it
whenever you want or in colorado sure
eight months
think about what i want you to do is
when you see this when you see this
protest out there these are people any
any moms out there any dads
ever look at an ultrasound
any of you have a baby born two weeks
early three weeks early they can already
be aborted in states they'll say well
not many of those occur still in the
tens of thousands
i think one is too many you're gonna
tell me that wasn't a life
these people are protesting they are
furious that states have the right to
say we're not virginia we're not going
to make a baby comfortable if it
survives an abortion and decide what to
do with its life that's the governor of
virginia ralph northam that former
governor that's what he said
they're protesting that texas can say
we're not colorado you cannot have a
seven eight month old abortion
and we're gonna
limit it depending on the state uh 20
weeks 16 weeks 12 weeks
eight
weeks which should be a non-issue if the
argument is true the vast majority of
abortions uh occur uh you know within
the first uh first 12 weeks anyway great
well then who then who cares probably it
looks like lane has a couple of people
and then we also have a quote from obama
in the map for you okay oh wonderful
that's gonna that's not going to make me
want my shotgun with a toe trigger
okay uh ginger snap are you there can
you hear me sir
yeah can you hear me yep yes i can okay
who are you with so i'm with a couple of
the pro-life uh crowd here and they're
of course they're pretty second ago
yeah right they don't look insanely
hideous so obviously they're pro-life
but um they were just talking to me a
second ago
about um threats being made against them
actually so what what did if you could
just speak kind of loudly okay um well
the lady with the megaphone
and the shaved head said do you want me
to hit you with this
i was like no and she's like
well then why did she ask
so they're very friendly you know you
can see this is peaceful
ask her on a scale from one to ten how
surprised was she that this abortion
activist had a shaved head
so stephen wants me to ask you on a
scale of one to ten how surprised were
you that the abortion actually just had
a shaved head
um
they're too nice yeah they're too nice
i'm like the lady who wanted to hit them
on a head like an acme cartoon
yes i i mean
so they're very nice they're very nice
people yeah well tell them thank you
that we do appreciate that they're out
there uh doing that work and ask them
how if if they were to set odds
what are they willing to bet that things
get violent uh over the course of this
weekend based on being on the ground
yeah so what do you guys think are the
chances that violence breaks out that
there's
i don't know i guess like uh george's
boyfriend stuff
what was the specifics
uh well i mean it's already happened
there's already been destruction to
practice
and that hasn't even been overturned so
they've snuck out that it will now that
it's they also said they were going to
like storm the supreme court like jump
over the gates and i don't see that
happening so yeah that i don't know
they'll get too winded
an insurrection
so yeah that sounds like an insurrection
gingersnap doesn't it that that does
sound like threats of an instruction i
don't think they they should do that
that sounds like a bad thing they might
not get in trouble because you know yes
but
no nobody i i don't know
it's a bad deal all right i should not
do that all right okay but stephen
didn't want to say thank you very much
for being out here and we appreciate
that thank you yeah thank you so just
tell them just tell them to go be pretty
in front of the abortion activist and
that and that in itself will enrage them
it will piss them off you just said just
go be pretty in front of them that's
gonna kind of ruin their day so i think
he's probably got something there just
us you know stephen powder all right we
gotta go junior snap we'll be right back
let's go to nancy pelosi uh who is of
course entirely sober on cnn her own
jamaican consultation with her doctor
her faith her family
not some right-wing politicians
that donald trump and mitch mcconnell
pack the court with
while republicans seek to punish and
control wait hold on a second democrats
talk the court ferociously [ __ ] you how
about that he didn't pack the court
he appointed within the number that has
been this cruel ruling is outrageous the
same number for for for uh does it go
1800s and by the way this is the reason
that the number was settled upon was
because originally it changed people
make that argument because district
courts change and because people would
have to travel and finally said okay
this is how we're we are going to
organize and design the supreme court
and there have been many
many uh legal briefings that have issued
uh statements and opinions regarding the
reasoning behind the supreme court
justices the numbers that we have right
now nine and why it should not packing
is expanding it because you don't like
the ruling like you said
like keith oberman said like your
representative said appointing
a justice because someone else retired
is not packing the court see how they
use language and they lie right now
nancy pelosi is lying let's go back to
completely sober pelosi who's about to
blow a point two four senators and
saying that they
they respected
sarah decision the the president of the
court
that they respected the right of privacy
and the constitution of the united
states doesn't apply here
did you hear that
were they not telling the truth then
they were
again
just getting to the gun issue because
really
in preparation for this morning please
do really an exalted state about what
happened it exalted
senate yesterday who exalted you
yourself
to the dangerous decision of this
trumpian supreme court that they made
yesterday
but a way to take us to as the bill is
called community safety
were you in that state when these armed
guards were around you escorting you to
your car
and then to your office and i'm going to
have to leave momentarily because we
just finished voting on the rule with
more on guards around yeah right now
she's surrounded by armed guards of
course
and we expect a good bipartisan vote on
it in the house we congratulate the
senate on the work that they have done
and the timeliness of it to be passed in
the senate in a strong bipartisan way on
a day
when the court made such a dangerous
dangerous decision it's been a two
martini morning
uh we will uh that's very conservative
refrain are that keep deadly weapons out
of dangerous hands by encouraging states
to establish extreme risk protection
order laws
or po otherwise known as red flag laws
oh helps put into straw purchases we
don't need to hear anymore go put on
your desmond tutu scarf you weirdo
so
let's read the uh uh uh president barack
obama statement
who by the way you know served as
president under uh current former vice
president uh joe biden yeah yeah
this is what he
said gonna be hard with a sick voice
now now today the supreme court not only
reversed nearly 50 years of precedent
it relegated the most intensely personal
decision
someone can make to the whims of
politicians and ideologues
attacking the essential freedoms of
millions of americans now hold on a
second
the whims of politicians and ideologues
by allowing these politicians who are
changed out regularly to create laws
that are representative of their voting
constituents i would say that
roe v wade
put this in the hands of ideologues on
the court
because it strips the states of that
right
it stripped the states of the right to
make decisions regarding an issue that
isn't a fundamental right right and the
most intensely personal decision hey
hold on a second
why is it always the most intensely
personal decision when it comes to an
abortion
isn't it an intensely personal decision
when you decide
who your mate is going to be this is the
problem with all of this sex is not
inconsequential
we act like abortion is an intensely
personal decision
but choosing who you mount is not
we're not animals
we're not animals and we don't we
shouldn't create laws to accommodate
human beings being animals this is their
mindset the most intensely personal
decision no it's not it's not the most
intensely personal decision not as
intensely personal as the bath houses
you decided to attend
it's unbelievable
this is democracy those people can be
voted out yes at the state level you
know what's not fair is having a senate
vote on something in a house vote on
something that the majority of americans
don't agree with just because
the democrats might have a majority
right now that doesn't feel fair you
know what it's scary a local issue an
issue that's not supposed to be federal
so let me be clear it's not supposed to
be done at the federal level having them
decide for you you know what's great
having a state that makes a law that you
disagree with and then you organizing a
campaign to get them voted out because
you live in that state and you can
affect local politics i thought you were
going to say junior mints well i was
going to go it's great this was next
above i was thinking about junior mints
that's what's great you're in a more
substantive direction no you're
absolutely right and this is this is
just the issue that we are dealing with
right now the most intensely personal i
think here's conspiracy you guys can
comment below by the way please hit like
share
we have ginger snap on the ground um i
don't know how long this is going to be
going this is an impromptu stream
i think they're scared because for as
much as states like arizona states like
texas they're claiming are going purple
because of a latino vote well now
they've seen that's actually not exactly
what they expected now this is not a
justification of open borders of course
not that's not what i'm saying
but they know
that if the 10 percent who they are
hoping will vote the 10 of illegal
immigrants who they are hoping will vote
to swing elections they know that if
just that same percentage of legal
hispanic voters vote
and they are educated on the issue of
abortion that st there is going to be a
red wave oh yeah of abortion laws you
will be hard-pressed to find more
pro-life people than hispanic americans
notably mexican catholics
and they're afraid of that
they're afraid of this monster that they
have created going oh my gosh we didn't
think about this and really the reason
they're afraid is because this is giving
authority back to the states look look
here's what i'm saying i think that
abortion i think it's murder and i think
just like murder is federally illegal i
think that it should be illegal that's
not where we are today this ruling today
just said you know what some states say
that it's not murder and some states say
that it's murder at a certain point
like when there's a heartbeat right or
like when it's viable right they're just
saying uh that's what the court said
here's the issue is
you can change if you think that murder
should be legal
you can still do that in your state you
can still do that in new york you can
still do that in california you can
still do that in colorado this is not a
reason to get violent and by the way
seeing what is happening right now and
seeing these calls to violence
is it any wonder
that it's your constitutional right to
keep and bear arms and by the way that
the one of the stupidest funniest clips
that i saw on i think it was msnbc
yesterday they were saying well the
supreme court uh ignored that
well-regulated militia the first part of
that clause again this is the lie well
regular militia being necessary to a
secure and free p the right of the
people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed and then you have auxiliary
documents who is the militia
anyone any male
able to serve
that's the militia that's what they
meant they met well regulated meant
effective
meant people who are familiar with
trained
hopefully men if you are a man of legal
age and at that point it was pretty damn
young that's why they had like 10 kids
because they were more they were more
coach hands
there's any man who can pick up a gun
and fight off the king
or throw some tetley's in the harbor has
the right
to pick up that gun it's very very clear
the left is lying when they say well
regular mushroom that means the uh uh
the us national guard no it doesn't that
didn't exist that means uh oh hold on a
second we're talking about the right to
privacy that means abortion what no it
doesn't no
donald trump packed the court no he
didn't didn't expand the number of
supreme court justices
if you actually look at what again what
the left would have today this is an
important day
what would the left have
if unchecked
yesterday
we have the supreme court striking down
new york saying that you can't carry a
firearm
saying people have the right to carry a
firearm and by the way
it's not nearly as wide reaching as you
think i'm a little concerned when you
read uh kavanaugh's opinions where he's
allowing for restrictions that i would
argue are unconstitutional right and i
think what's more important is the
dissenting opinions like briar uh
breyers
i'll get to that in a second but
yesterday they said you have the right
to carry firearms
okay
and now today's saying well you know
what the states have the right to
states have the right the elected
representatives have the right to say
you can't have an abortion after this
point because those people there
consider it murder and this
unfortunately has not been defined at
the federal level they want to change
the rules to all of that yeah
what would they do will california new
york tell you they won't let you carry
firearms what would they do if unchecked
well they've told you abortion up until
and including nine months period
that's what they do in their states
and they just want to make sure that
that is enshrined at a federal level
and then [ __ ] about you being an
authoritarian let me ask you i don't
know you watching right now
i don't know i don't feel i don't feel
authoritarian charles i don't feel
authoritarian in that i believe
if you have the right to own a firearm i
can't
stop you i don't feel like that makes me
authoritarian i don't feel
like an authoritarian and saying all
right okay look states you could murder
babies up until nine months texas
chooses not to ah it doesn't feel is it
just me that doesn't feel authoritarian
you know what feels authoritarian
ignoring the court's rulings
and ensuring
that only some justices decide all of
these laws as it relates to your rights
giving them more power they're saying
democracy dies while their proposed
solution today we just read you these
quotes the proposed solutions
are to give the courts
who are unelected more power by
expanding it and changing the rules
exactly the court was never given that
power by the constitution and so here's
i've got two solutions to this problem
one is fantastic for us and the other
one will just show you how stupid you
please tell me one is a fumigation tent
well
they're gonna need it
mostly for gingersnap when it gets done
talking to some of these people and we
we actually just got someone to talk to
oh gingersnap okay hold that thought in
a minute do you need a note to write it
down good you got good short-term memory
he plays his dueling back all right
gingersnap you are there sir okay i'm
gonna listen in you do your thing
okay so i'm talking to you um what's
your name edward edwin and edwin is a
anti-abortion democrat
catholic so
a rare breed i haven't met anyone that
fits that description at all so
how do you feel can you ask edwin ask
edwin real quick
okay okay ask him his ethnicity where is
he what what's what is he uh hispanic
american ask him
do you have a hispanic background yes i
am how do you think most of the hispanic
community feels about this actually
about 55 percent
more or less the uh hispanics when
they're quoted they're actually the only
ethnicity that tends to be against
abortion that either wants severe
restrictions or just banning entirely
and it's only about between 40 and 45
percent of hispanics they actually you
know are pro-choice so you know so when
it comes to demographics hispanics tend
to be pro-life versus you know just
being pro-choice
and obviously you know all that has to
influence you know their hispanics
countries you know you really don't talk
about you know abortion or a lot i mean
as right now it's only
feminism in latin america that is really
pushing that abortion right yeah
abortion debate but most uh
well most people
yeah ask him what would make him a
democrat what would make him vote
democrat if he's pro-life
so with something like an issue as big
as this pro-life generally tends to be
more like a republican position so what
makes you a democrat that holds this
position well you know
i come from a county which is uh robson
county north carolina which is actually
very racially diverse we have actually
have been democrats well we actually uh
i actually checked the demographics for
every three democrats there is one
republican
and we also don't have the abortion
clinton which you know if it's a county
that's heavily democratic you would
expect to see abortion but that's not
the case so you know there's this thing
in which you know there are still you
know probably democrats just that it's
in the rural communities that are
controlled by democrats versus you know
the liberal cities but is it is it going
to be hard for you to support an
administration that is very against this
view that you hold well actually my
friendly actually did uh voted for uh
fighting for president however i also
didn't avoid republicans at the
federal level which you know the house
representatives in the senate you know
because i'm like i just didn't like
trump at all and that's the thing with a
lot of democrats is that they do not
like trump however you know they do want
you know personal restrictions so you
know sometimes you have to play along
and you know vote but ask him if he's
glad that because of the appointees from
trump to the court that we have this
ruling really have that much control
however after this i really fear that
some credit card will be more abortion
or
just to break you down a little bit and
i know you understand this but with the
justices that overturned
yeah they that only happened probably
because they were appointed by trump yes
which you know i actually
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just gas prices ask him can you give him
two good things this abortion and gas
prices okay
well can you give us two good things
abortion and gas prices they were a
little bit lower before
well you know
the abortion gas prices
just two things well i mean everything
it is it's the whole economy that
economy was going to tell you a little
bit i do
partially do uh blame you know the
shutting down the businesses i mean i
understand you know why they did it but
come on it's been two years like open
the country off you sound like a
republican yeah i was going to say
i still support social welfare okay
which is now which is going to be in the
now about life pro-life you know for pro
libraries you know some uh republicans
they're like well you know let's not
focus on the government but focus on
non-profits however the way i feel is
that steel government has an important
role to play and help the lives now i'm
not saying to have a complete
takeover of the government however what
i am saying is that the government
should just be there to support people
okay like that should be the role the
government i don't know some republicans
have a different view right you know uh
that's them i have my different view
which is why i'm proud i'm democrat like
i've always said i do appreciate you
taking the time to talk to people really
thank you thank you gingersnap this is
like i've said the latino and the
hispanic and the black
voters in the democrat party they are
the only moderates left and so you give
me you know this you give me half hour
with that guy he will never vote
democrat again i guarantee you and the
same thing happened when we went and we
spoke with black americans in the
streets of deep ellum in dallas it just
requires a little bit of education that
guy right there is a man precluded from
voting democrat if he fully understood
the depths of their depravity
all right i'll check back in with ginger
snap he looks uh he looks a little bit
like a ginger in the headlights he saw
another girl he wanted to go interview
ginger snap loves the ladies he loves
the ladies he likes them a lot let me go
back to the points that i was going to
make constitutional amendment if you
think that there should be because it's
not in there and that's what the supreme
court just said this is not something
that is protected by the constitution
united states or the amendments so you
can do a constitutional amendment for a
right to abortion go for it the bar is
really high what you'll find is you'll
never get anywhere wouldn't that have to
be at a convention of the state yeah
yeah so they would have to go through an
entire process and and the fact that
they don't want to do that they don't
want to go through a difficult process
they want a power grab through
authoritarianism i know that's what they
said they said look we're not going to
get every single one of these things
right so we're going to leave a
mechanism in place to make sure that you
can adjust this as you see fit but it
isn't going to be at the whims of nine
people it's not going to be at the whims
of congress it's going to be a much
harder process the other thing that you
can do
get the hell out of our states if you
want abortion on demand please move to
california move to colorado move to new
york move to illinois i don't want to
move to new york the economy's so bad
though well then don't vote for it here
don't vote for it here leave leave now
yeah guess what leave right now
because we have
because of our election system right
because we have an election system that
doesn't just use the popular vote i
don't care if you stay i would rather
you leave you brought your stupid
policies with you when you moved here
and you're screwing up a good thing get
out there's two solutions yes if you're
in texas and you don't like uh you don't
like carrying firearms you might as well
just get the hell out well yeah that's
true one other american you don't like
spaghetti and meatballs restart
researchers do me a favor really quickly
there's a lot of stuff going around
right now about uh clarence justice
clarence thomas he's apparently writing
a uh writing in a concurring opinion
that he released that is some people are
saying that it's calling for the a
reconsideration of protection for
contraception same-sex marriages and
same-sex relationships there seems to be
a lot of
bs floating around right now yeah being
pushed by the left find that if you can
his concurring opinion and let us know
kind of what it says that being said i
wouldn't be surprised if clarence thomas
was like gay couples getting married oh
that's just weird that's nasty that is
weird
or it's completely reasonable it's
completely reasonable yeah just totally
i'm just saying it could go either way i
like that guy okay let me read another
quote here from hillary clinton this is
the reaction from the left we're doing
this live you can use a promo code uh
save scotus you'll get 20 off mug
club.com club as you see right now there
are no ads
that's what keeps the lights on as
actual viewers like you not a foreign
caliphate
um hillary clinton said
[Laughter]
no
yeah just like a like an eagle or a
seagull stuck in an oil spill
get the dawn no don't get the dawn get
the palm olive so we can have a
commercial all right let it drown says
most americans believe the decision to
have a child is one of the most sacred
decisions there is
yes yes end phrase exactly
this is what has happened since the
beginning of time
is you either sit two lives become one
two fleshes become one and you say we
want to have a child the term used to be
i am with child
right or
oopsie and you've got a kid on your
hands but either way the decision has
been made
this is the language that they try and
turn
they act as though the only decision
takes place
after
contraception there are many decisions
before that many decisions before that
let's be clear there are decisions in
how you approach dating or courting as
it used to be known there are decisions
in how you decide
on your future mate partner there are
decisions on whether you want it to be a
one-night stand or not which by the way
is something i think is is is very
corrosive to our society then there are
decisions on if you decide that this is
the person whether it's a one night
standard your significant partner
which form of contraception are you
using hormonal birth control there's now
male hormonal birth control i don't know
if it's out on the market yet it's
basically just enough testosterone to
ruin your boys but not enough for
performance enhancing benefit wonderful
you want to use a rubber hey when it
comes to rubber what do you want do you
want ultra sensitive do you want
lambskin do you want ribs for her
pleasure you can get a french tickler or
there's a diaphragm
there's an iud for some of them and i
know that's a whole different but my
point is there are many decisions that
you make
you know what women can before abortion
yeah you know what they can also do
sorry to interrupt they can track their
ovulation as well yeah
that's a very effective way to limit
it's a somewhat effective way well it's
a somewhat effective way it is let's be
honest it's not a very effective way
tracking ovulation is a very effective
way to limit your chances yes to limit
your chances but it is not a foolproof
system no no not at all also special
especially after a couple of zemas
that app isn't getting checked for
notifications all right
says this one of the most sacred
decisions there is and that such
decision decisions should remain between
patients and their doctors today's
supreme court opinion will live in
infamy they use this language do you
know what that's from you know what
that's from
a day that will live in infamy
comment you know what it's from yeah
the speech of pearl harbor
giving the states the right to put some
limitations or the states the right to
have no limitations on abortions they
are comparing to pearl harbor which
before 9 11 was the most devastating
attack on american soil
and some people are going to be
surprised why it gets violent this
weekend
will live in infamy as a step backwards
for women's rights and human rights well
i think sorry you misspelled [ __ ] yeah
it'll be a step backward for whole wars
pronounce two syllables who wors and
what do i mean by that i mean women who
aren't sexually responsible and then
decide that they are going to abort a
human life yep yep may not like it not
saying all women are [ __ ]
but people who think that it's a
necessity abortion otherwise you cannot
be a responsible female adult or someone
as someone is violating your rights
or it's science we used to value
pregnancy it used to be a beautiful
thing like for you to be able to get
pregnant and bring a child into this
world and now it's an inconvenience
because we want you to pursue a career
and then wake up at 35 and realize holy
crap i'm not happy with this and i'm not
saying that women can't be happy in a
career and be happy in a ceo role or
some other position of power and
authority in business and that they
can't start businesses not at all what
i'm saying is you will never experience
joy
like bringing a child into the world you
alone get the privilege of doing that
and what you're saying is it's an
inconvenience it's an inconvenient time
you know who's going to celebrate this
law the almost 1 million kids who will
potentially be born this year that would
have been aborted hey let's go to cnn
right now because they have someone live
on location let's see what she's doing
and what kind of a job they're doing at
cnn here how they're uh
how they're portraying it and it's grown
a lot i'll introduce you to two people
uh that we're speaking with uh this is
lori miller she's come from california
um oh it's a bad start
sorry
sorry about that um so this is this is
they're arguing she's worse than ginger
snap can you talk to me about what
brings you out here today kind of looks
better well i have a 17 year old
daughter so it's very important to me
that she has a right to choose when she
becomes a mother she does when she's
[Applause]
you live in california [ __ ] don't know
what's next i don't think we have the
systems in place to support
young women having children when they're
not ready well then don't don't have sex
so here's what it comes down to and now
it's the broad and now it's the boodle
and nothing is safe name that movie line
comment below it started with i wanted
to have the right and then we don't have
the systems in place for these uh
children that we don't want so what does
it come to
another expanding of the social safety
net yeah that's always the pivot the
argument is i want my daughter by the
way you're in california okay you're in
the land of abortion on demand and by
the way i don't know the stats i'm
pretty sure some of the highest number
of welfare recipients certainly in urban
areas
out of the country i know you if you
talk about some people in the in the
hills of west virginia right people who
are very poor if you talk about urban
areas i'm pretty sure that los angeles
and san francisco are up there so it's
not like california
is affected by this california has the
social safety net she's saying that they
don't have and by the way california can
still have their
outrageously silly abortion laws let's
continue with cnn because now she's uh
speaking with uh i can't see it's a
small thing a swiffer
she didn't have the means to have a
child at this moment and i was the only
person that was there telling her we
didn't know each other very well we were
only a couple months into uh our senior
year and i told her i was like you know
i i don't know why but i feel as though
you are meant to be a mother to this
child and i am going to be here for you
i am going to support you every single
step of the way you know no matter what
you decide to do but just know that you
are strong enough well the mo she ended
up booking the abortion appointment and
the morning that she was going to take
the two-hour drive to our nearest
abortion facility uh the night before
she had actually filled up her tires
with air just to make sure that it was
all good she could make the drive and
she woke up in the morning she called me
while i was in class and i said i have
to answer obviously and she said she's
crying and and she was like i didn't go
i didn't go and i was like you couldn't
go and she goes no my top my uh the tire
the air in my tire was flat my tire was
flat this morning when i went to leave
like i feel like this is my sign to keep
this child and she has gone you know she
has taken her circumstances and just
achieved so much not only is she an
amazing mother to a soon to be
three-year-old beautiful little boy but
she is now living in her own place she's
starting school she has a great job and
she did it i want women to know i want
everyone to know that women are stronger
than their circumstances and no matter
what situation that you find yourself in
the post road generation the pro-life
generation is here to say you can
abortion tells women you can't you can't
go to college you can't achieve your
dreams you have to have the right to end
the life of your child so that you can
live your dream and i think that's
misogyny i think that that is wonderful
we're better than that and get her off
the air and clearly yeah
she's not going to ask a follow-up watch
no savannah craven i appreciate your
time there you go
we saw her ask a follow-up to the
california broad who was dumb as a bag
of hammers and then this lady starts
getting on a roll she's like oh my god i
can't say anything because she's black
got the feet no no no go to camera two
abort the feed yeah aboard the feed
look this is just this is uh so this is
one of those situations um well let me
read this too can i read this quote do
you mind if i read the reverend yeah
okay go ahead and you can meet my mic i
have to blow my nose it's gonna piss me
off here all right so reverend
raphael warnock i'm outraged by the
supreme court's decision as a pro-choice
pastor remember that i'll never back
down from this fight women must be able
to make their own health care decisions
not politicians i am sorry it is
impossible
to read the bible
and be pro-choice
the reason that i say that is the bible
is very clear on when that
baby
can understand what's going on in the
world outside of it when god knows it as
it knits it in its mother's womb right
he or she
there is no
room the catholic church doesn't provide
room jewish culture doesn't provide room
for this christian faith doesn't provide
room for this because the bible does not
provide room for this for you to be a
pro-choice pastor you have to not this
shouldn't be a surprise though because
we talked about this guy uh during
easter he's the one that tweeted the
meaning of easter is more transcendent
than the resurrection of jesus christ
whether you are a christian or not
through a commitment to helping others
we are able to save ourselves no you're
not no this guy is not a guy's not a
pastor this guy this guy's a false he's
not even a prophet he's just a charlatan
he's a snake oil salesman by the way we
have amy klobuchar um i mean just
serial mediocritist
she's great she said
no one is better at mediocre than amy
klobuchar
she said what the supreme court just did
is an outrage a woman has a right to
make her own health care choices
did she say choices twice hmm choices
choices choices choices
from now until november yes she did she
wrote it twice oh so we can see that
she's had a three
a three martini brunch yeah her and
pelosi
you know what i love to do is i love to
tweet after cosmos
her own health care choices choices from
now until november we fight wait a
second fight isn't that inciting
violence
no no isn't that inciting violence which
by the way fight like hell the shirts
are available i don't care you can say
fight i know what you mean but you
impeached
a president for saying fight like hell
after
unlike you
amy aggressively mediocre klobuchar he
had the qualifier make your voices heard
peacefully i didn't see you just say
that i saw you only safe fight
time to start using their rules against
them yeah time to start taking their
rules rolling them up and grabbing your
your shovel your screwdriver whatever
you have your mallet and shove it down
their mouth yeah we can't keep playing
by a different set of rules you said
fight impeach yeah absolutely by the way
this is why it's so important for us to
go out and vote she's saying all right
we gotta fight all the way till november
make sure you go out and vote because
they're going to try to do every single
thing that they can to overturn this to
pack the court to use this as a pretense
oh they're expanding gun laws no they're
not they're just recognizing a law
that's already on the books in the
constitution the second amendment you
have this right they're giving you the
ability not to get an abortion anymore
right they're prohibiting you from
getting no they're not they're sending
it back to the states they're gonna use
it go out and vote we were this close if
donald trump does not get elected
president this day never happens yep
just think about that in fact this day
probably never happens we probably have
like a
a 7-2 court or a 6-3 court the other way
if donald trump by the way do you think
if that happened they would be calling
to add seats and pack the court of
course not no
to end the filibuster to get rid of
democracy all the things that the
democrats want to do right now to
protect democracy are ending democracy
and you know what let's read some chats
uh and we can read them live but i want
to read some more from the bill and then
to some more reactions which are
absolutely alyssa milano is just pee
your pants funny so
page 37 and the bill and all references
are available a lot of credit.com we
have sorry the bill the opinions are up
there uh to read uh and i believe we
also have the bills you know in which
the opinions are based just like
yesterday with the uh the
texas i was gonna say just like
yesterday with the new york conceal
carry law
page 37 says the most striking feature
of the descent is the absence of any
serious uh oh no sorry this is something
i put in there yesterday um
no no this is from today the most
striking feature of the descent is the
absence of any serious discussion of the
legitimacy of the state's interest in
protecting fetal life this is evident in
the analogy that the dissent draws
between the abortion rights and the
rights recognized in griswold
contraception eisenstadt the same
lawrence sexual conduct with a member of
the same sex and obergefell same-sex
marriage that view is evident throughout
the dissent the descent has much to say
about the effects of pregnancy on women
the burdens of motherhood and the
difficulties faced by poor women these
are important concerns however the
dissent convinces no similar regard for
a state's interest in protecting
prenatal life is that the clarence
thomas is that what we're talking about
that people are bitching about is that
clarence can someone tell me is that
clarence thomas because he was
discussing the legal precedent there but
obergefell is that is that what they're
saying that was at least the list right
there for sure i don't know if that's
the concurring opinion i know but is
that what twitter is trying to say means
that clarence thomas is coming for your
coming for your short fights
that's probably where they're pulling it
from yeah that's what i'm guessing can
you guys tell me 30 seconds or less guys
okay lane has a pro choice okay sure
okay great uh 30 seconds or less guys
just let me know if that's clarence
thomas let's go to gingersnap down there
on location again the promo code is safe
scotus gingersnap go ahead yeah so what
do you think is going to happen in north
carolina
we need you to lean in
lane
we have a democratic governor
so that is going to have an impact
and our democratic governor is
definitely moderate to
but we've got some constitutional
amendments that go through
uh recently that limit
access to
ask him how the abortion issue affects
transgenders
so do you think this abortion issue is
going to like have downstream effects on
transgender issues
it may it's like that because
[Applause]
a lot of transgenders have abortions
do you think that this ruling isn't
constitutional
like do you think this follows the rule
of the constitution
uh
that's very interesting uh it was quick
to answer
for the them
court
and of course the constitutional framers
had no idea
that this would become an issue any more
than they had any idea that gun rights
wait what
so is he suggesting that the founders
would have been supportive of modern
abortion
so do you think if they would have known
this specific issue would arrive do you
think the founders of the country would
have supported abortion rights
abortion was fairly common practice
uh throughout most uh you know western
cultures back back in that day and age
yeah
just say [ __ ]
they who's they when you say they like
who are you
no who wants to do away
who are the people that want to do away
with this specifically
no you're not i'm really curious
where in the bible would you find
support for this when people ask that
question you're like you're a christian
how do you believe in abortion how would
you answer that question well there is
no support anywhere in fact i'm sure it
was blindly practiced in the ancient
world
[Music]
i think judah supported it they both
indicated that there is not widespread
uh support for the pro-life position in
the muslim community
but abortion is actually practiced for
some of you you're not muslim you're
christians
well i tell them also the muslim belief
is to kill
killing christians and jews and infidels
is okay and gays and gays
so are you saying the muslims support
pro-life support pro-choice as a whole
of choice this muslims are pro-choice a
lot of them are they also are very pro
like killing people that don't
yeah
so but uh
in some parts of the muslim community
it's not it's not considered
as absolute as it is
because he just acknowledged that islam
is a culture of death across the board
and i've not done enough research to be
able to go farther with that
all right okay so what do you like what
do you think is going to be the
immediate result of this
nothing
but it uh of course it's going to a
power state like
right i just mean like on the ground
today do you think anything he's gonna
yes
no
do we have a decision coming today no no
like i didn't know if like you thought
there was going to be like people taking
to the streets huge marches violence
a large enough
counter protest so the pro-life people
are the dangerous ones
we get huge numbers yeah both
for fighting back all right lane we'll
go back gingersnap we'll go back to you
we can't really hear them so much uh
which not hearing that uh that uh old
broad is a probably a good thing yeah we
are apparently her husband is into
pilgrim sex yeah so hey what what you
were reading before that was still a
leader we have clarence thomas further
down okay we have clearance but here let
me just go uh
let me just address what what we just
heard
he acknowledged think about this for a
second think of how scary it is he
acknowledged there's no constitutional
basis
he acknowledged i'm a christian but
there's no biblical basis to support
abortion
they acknowledged
it's going to affect them zero because
of states because of the state in which
they live i didn't hear which the state
and which they said
did they yeah they said nothing's going
to change in many of the states is what
they said they acknowledge that
and they're outraged anyway yeah there's
no common ground
with i'm sorry
demonic ideas it's demonic
it's demonic to abort to kill a seven
month six-month-old five-month-old for
it's to i'm sorry it's pure
evil
and these people support a platform and
what do i mean fringe no everyone barack
obama hillary clinton amy klobuchar
kamala harris joe biden elizabeth warren
none of them are willing to put any
limitations on abortions as part of the
democratic policy
yeah there's no nego we don't negotiate
with terrorists which isn't really true
we negotiate with terrorists all the
time yeah but
there's no cop finding common ground
with evil
yeah we have ocasio-cortez
oh let's see what she
of my says rule in a lot of ways
um
and
we're going to have to fight a long road
to get it back fight she said fight well
i mean that's a that's a good question
because they're kind of monsters
use this as an issue over the last two
months since you saw the the the leaked
opinion uh and uh it does not seem to
have moved the needle if uh if if at all
if it has not much again i think most
people are pretty entrenched with what
they believe on this particular issue
and what ought to happen what what i
think a lot of folks all right let me
read you guys the clarence thomas uh
concurring opinion this is what the left
is freaking out about just to be clear
so uh because like we said i guess we've
been seeing on twitter yeah people
saying that he's trying to ban gay
marriage i guess that uh what's his name
that uh uh h3 uh ethan klein ethan klein
yeah he was saying that
so uh
this is from clarence thomas his
concurring opinion on the uh subject
here of substantive due process i'll
read directly from it says because the
due process clause does not secure any
substantive rights it does not secure a
right to abortion
the court today declines to disturb
substantive due process jurisprudence
generally or the doctrine's application
in other specific contexts cases like
griswold versus connecticut that's the
right of married persons to obtain
contraceptives lawrence versus texas the
right to engage in private consensual
sexual acts obergefell versus hodges the
right to same-sex marriage are not an
issue
they're not at issue for this are not an
issue not should be underlined are not
an issue can someone bring up the tweets
about clarence thomas guys grab the
tweets that gerald was talking about or
where they're writing about clarence
thomas saying they're going after your
gay marriage because let me read this he
says that these are not an issue and
then he goes on to explain why the
court's abortion cases are unique this
is almost like again they'll look back
on this sort of like the left tries to
look back and twist the right of a
regulated militia right those commas
matter and the auxiliary documents
matter the supporting documents that say
who what is the militia it's every man
yeah right here it's not just are not an
issue meaning same-sex marriage meaning
contraceptives there's another part he
says the court's abortion cases are
unique
meaning unique what is that meaning
separate and apart from these other
issues it couldn't be more clear that
he's saying this affects these other
cases
none at all he writes c ante and there's
some numbers here as far as uh pages
and rulings and no party has asked us to
decide whether our entire 14th amendment
jurispudence must be preserved or
revised for that reason in future cases
we should reconsider all this court's
substantive due process precedence in
the sources including griswold lawrence
and obergefell because any substantive
due process decision is demonstrably
erroneous we have a duty to correct the
error established in those precedents so
he's saying this is different those are
not at issue right now and he's saying
we will need to take these cases
on a case-by-case basis as to whether
they fall under
due process right now keep in mind if
they don't fall under due pro this is
the problem with the 14th amendment it's
been used as a sunbrella of
anything you want why uh privacy
and that's not really what the 14th
amendment says so we can have sex uh
we can do whatever we want in our
bedroom well sure and by the way i don't
care of course you should be able to do
whatever you want in your bedroom that's
one that seems appropriate to me yeah
why because of privacy okay
we have the right to speak private okay
understand but then they say and we have
a right to privacy uh abortion
that's not a privacy issue and i would
even argue
the same sex marriage issue at a federal
level is not really a privacy issue so
that's one that may require
reconsidering
and again it would go to the states
where if you just say well hold on a
second this can't be filed under the
14th amendment because then the 14th
amendment doesn't mean anything it would
need to be brought before us in another
case right so that we could say and
that's how i'm reading this i'm not
reading that he is saying we need to
overturn the actual decisions in those
cases no he's not getting it is saying
if you're basing this on the 14th
amendment like the court and right here
it says it in future cases we should
reconsider all of this court's
substantive due process precedence right
meaning in future cases when they come
we can't just depend on the precedence
we have for substantive due process
because we've just said
that we got one wrong right and we're
not applying this correctly the the 14th
amendment isn't being applied correctly
here so in future cases we need to keep
that in mind so it has to be brought
under a different standard it would have
to be would have to be a case that goes
to the supreme court on one of these
issues where it was decided based on the
14th amendment and what he is also
saying by the way is we need
to observe the precedence meaning that
that would be included in how they rule
and whether that president whether it
makes sense because we did get one wrong
here
but right now today
he says these are not an issue the
court's abortion cases are unique yeah
the context is the abortion cases are
not the same as these other cases right
and he could be strengthening that so a
reason i bring that up is because rgb
said the same thing she said the 14th
amendment and i think you read a quote
from her earlier don't say rgb
i want to punch you i want to punch you
in your face so bad when you say that
ruth bader ginsburg okay right not a
hip-hop artist former justice
not judge chris cross he's not odb okay
she said that the 14th amendment would
not sustain roe in the long term that it
would be overturned that's exactly what
clarence thomas is saying here that if
you wanted to strengthen it hold on
let's see elizabeth warren with her
parkinson's shakes
those points here quickly the the fact
that this now goes back to the states
your home state of massachusetts the
highest court they're upholding the
right to an abortion passing laws to
protect abortion rights we're seeing
more of that in a number of of bluer
states the reality of what can happen
you tried the legislative route not too
long ago that failed an executive order
isn't going to reinstate this and even
if it did it could be overturned by
another president as you know so
realistically speaking when you say
there is work to be done legislation can
someone bring up the massachusetts
abortion laws put it at the top of this
document look like what the limitations
looks like getting
two more democrats in the united states
senate who are willing to support both
filibuster reform and making roe versus
wade the law of the land it means
hanging on to the house of
representatives and it means passing roe
into law
that's what november will be all about
no it's not what it's all about it's
about gas prices it's about inflation
it's about people not being able to find
a job it's about people not being able
to afford housing it's about people not
able to afford rent it's about the fact
that you have pardoned my language
[ __ ] up at every single aspect of your
job your entire party and you screwed up
roe v wade you screwed up the precedence
here he had a this you had a ruling that
you didn't like and so you want to make
it about this and all of your calls
we've heard every single leftist
representatives that we have seen on
television and if you read their tweets
use the words fight
you want to stir up violence just like
you did with black lives matter and
within the first four months there were
two billion dollars worth of damages and
not just money there were thousands of
officer casualties dozens of murders
largely black neighborhoods largely
black people you want to do the same
thing now that's what you want to do
because there's no way you can win the
election on the issues none whatsoever
you know it we know it
the latino democrat out there in front
of the supreme court just now knows it
and so she says this is what it is all
about it's not what it's all about you
can keep saying that because you want it
to be that way but it's not what it's
all about this is done
this is done take the l like a man oh
that's right you can't do that it goes
back to yesterday is there any
accountability women should have the
right to make their decisions hold on a
second are women ever held accountable
for the decisions
that they make
before we get to abortion time
just like that that uh uh black lady
could have been biracial
who we aptly said you know compared to a
swiffer that was just you know for jokes
but i love what she had to say hopefully
she has a sense of humor
i think she does she just said it's this
is misogyny saying that women do not
have
any accountability for their decisions
hey we know that men do we know that men
do now we don't have any choice this is
the issue here right now i'm going to
give you a male's perspective he's like
why aren't you talking about from
because i'm not a female okay so we're
giving you the legal perspective and we
hear from woman after woman after woman
after woman after woman after a woman
that's all we've heard on cnn as though
it's the only opinion that matters let
me speak here by the way this is
important for women okay
more important than women talking about
their choices
is how it affects
the sexual dynamics the relational
dynamics between you and men if you have
a guy who says he supports your right to
an abortion he's probably a piece of
[ __ ] just to let you know but you know
what guys don't have a choice but we do
have the bill
we do have the bill you want to know why
40-something percent of young men don't
want to get married
you both choose to have sex
okay maybe it's an act maybe it's an
accident i hate to use that word maybe
you didn't plan on the pregnancy
or maybe you did but you both choose to
have sex a man and a woman takes two
there's a baby
the man has no say in the decision
you can terminate his son
that man can go to an ultrasound in a
state of colorado
have named his son
see his face see his fingers toes see
that he's a man see his penis not a sign
sex recognize it
and that woman
can make the unilateral decision
to kill it
that man cannot make a unilateral
decision to not pay child support
think about that for a second you think
it's going to be good for women
do you really think that abortion has
been good for women do you think it's
bread better men do you think it's bred
healthy relationships and you can argue
until you're blue in the face you know
what else this is one thing women when
you're sitting there bitching about
choice feminists by the way i know the
women who watch this are just as tired
and you know how i know go to lottery
with crowder.com tour
right you have you have thousands of
people at every show
and it's half women
and they're the biggest they're the
biggest crowd cheering
when we take a steaming dump on feminism
okay so let's separate that but feminism
is a problem
it's choice without accountability as
feminists shriek about choice
men don't have a choice they don't have
a choice in the life of that child they
don't have a choice if they have to
support that child
but even more
when you're a little girl
when you're told right all little girls
you can be anything you want to be what
are you told if you want to grow up and
you want to be a mom you want to be a
homemaker you want to be a stay-at-home
wife you're told hey you can be a
working woman or you can be a mom
right
the lie is you can do it all you can't
you do have to break up time you
probably have to work part-time you'll
have to prioritize but they tell you
that you can do anything you want to do
right you have the choice
and they complain about this in detroit
women aren't given a choice because it's
generally a man's world and work
in work you know it's tough to become a
ceo
that's because men never have a choice
if a young man says i want to be a dad
let me ask you this comment below
comment below
any man out there remember when you're a
boy having parents say yeah you can be a
stay-at-home dad
you can do whatever you want you can go
to school you can be a scientist you can
be an engineer
you can be a [ __ ] deadbeat
no if we want kids we don't have a
choice
as soon as we are old enough to know
that we want a wife and or a child we
have never been taught that we have the
choice to do whatever we want to be and
you know what women you know that you
are being honest if you are dating right
now
if you are dating right now and you walk
into
a blind date and you say what do you do
and the guy says well you know what i'm
working whatever it is i'm working in
arby's right now or even if he says i'm
a civil engineer right now but i really
just want to be a stay-at-home dad you
keep going on down that dating trail
because
it's not a deciding factor for men
men don't have a choice
we don't have a choice in our
responsibility
to provide and by the way that's because
it is a man's role i understand that
even in the time of dual income
households i'm not saying that a man
shouldn't be a protector and provider my
issue is with
applying it only when it's convenient
there's a give and take and a compromise
where's the give
how about that it has to be a joint
decision
why didn't you start with that when it
came to abortion
ah no vagina no opinion really well you
know how i know that's [ __ ] let me
read you some more commentary here
uh from um
from uh uh let's see who do we have we
have uh
alyssa milano if amy klobuchar
we have uh let me saw pocahontas there
and swallow elizabeth warren she said
six radical supreme court justices have
overturned nearly 50 years of precedent
they've decided that the government not
the person who is pregnant should make a
private health care decision and deny
women the right to control their own
bodies hold on a second
50 years of press deny let's let's take
these two things that she just said deny
women the right to control their own
bodies she's upset about that
interesting
elizabeth pocahontas you're also upset
about 50 years of precedent
who set that precedent
who was in the court in roe v wade
you didn't have a problem with judges
with dicks back then
now you do
you love the dicks when they pass the
laws you want
you vilify the dicks when they say you
know what you can't kill a baby
just be honest
just be honest feminists elizabeth
warren aoc you want no accountability
for your actions whatsoever just in the
last three days aoc shouldn't be
responsible for her own student debt
aoc shouldn't be responsible for her own
meals and travel because she's a public
servant
women shouldn't be responsible
for using contraception or picking their
mate
carefully
and doing their due diligence
amber heard shouldn't be responsible for
hating johnny depp because he made her
do it
these people
meaning radical
and by that are feminists
including the white knighting men
who go oh yeah i have a penis so i
shouldn't have an opinion
should not be in control at all in any
form of government that's a dangerous
thing
someone who refuses to take
accountability for their own actions you
know what we call that that's a
sociopath
feminism is simply i guess you could say
philosophically codified
sociopathy
that's all it is
you know what's a little crazy here too
seven white judges
put roe into effect
four white judges a black man and a
woman
voted that it should go back to the
states a woman did have a voice in this
are you forgetting that i might already
had a voice in this are you forgetting
that too right yeah we are one of those
radical feminists with lane right now
all right gingersnap let's go to the
shrieks the uh uh the dementors
to get medical treatment which we can't
get now for an abortion where are you
from i'm from kansas city missouri
okay so what like what are the laws in
missouri like now they just passed they
just outlawed it which means there's
absolutely no appointment
allowed in the state of missouri so that
was the first state to do so correct
today oh i think oklahoma may have also
no
issue i don't know if they i believe
missouri was the first one but i does
not surprise me now so does she have a
car
um
how when did you get here i got here uh
wednesday for a family vacation
i
heard the news
i jumped in an uber and i came down i
was out moved she must be fun
did this stop what i was doing and come
down here because it was just too too
overwhelming i i'm 72 years old i
remember my
girls in my high school dying from
illegal abortions
i thought she was gonna say that she
remembers custer's last stand
is the most shameful experience that i
can have
out as an american citizen
like and then to play devil's advocate
on the other side people that are like
okay but that's a living baby that is
being
killed over 800 000 they are losing
their liberties well like 800 000 per
year a year that's what they say
are they are going to get into that
debate why not
uh of course
cell formations in a fetus no art
beating heart a livable baby grab the
fetal charge ask her where it's okay
grab the fetal chart uh ginger snap
someone stole it
the woman has control of her body that
trumps everything it's a separate heart
what if there's two heartbeats is that
seven months healthy baby can we abort
it you want me to address that yes i
want to address tell her that's the
policy of the democratic platform six
weeks that's what people oppose
working in a fast food restaurant and
walmart on the weekends they can't make
rent they already have three children
why are they having so much sex then
why are they having so much sex if they
can't afford children okay that's you
just put your finger on it that's the
control of women see that what no wait
does a woman have a choice to have sex
you
cannot
have sex
under
conditions that we don't approve of what
what ask her if she asks her if she
believes in any accountability for
women's decisions before abortion ask
her if women are responsible for
anything that they do
so do they have any responsibility at
all women have any responsibilities they
have the same amount of responsibility
as men have so do men have a say in
abortion you said men have to pay child
support forever and they have to take
care of the baby
okay from the point of inception yeah
well when i see that we can talk but if
you think that's going to pass you're
wrong so does a man have a right to have
a say in the child uh living or being
aborted so
the man creates that helps create the
child right if they're the man have any
say over what happens to that child
it's under the control of the woman
i think she was going to say woman
i is there
free you your final stance just want to
make sure i understand is abortion on
man anytime any reason because it's the
woman's decision
i am going to go with that
versus this
so you're not going to get you're trying
to see the perfect solution i am trying
to seek the chest solution for the great
majority of women do you know what i do
for a living
in death penalty cases
i have seen
hundreds of clients
who have committed
heinous crimes and they're facing the
death penalty my
role histories and by mitigating
circumstances so you're saying people
that have abortion should get the death
penalty
i am saying
that
nice i wanted neglected abused
do not
end up as the citizens we want how about
you don't neglect and abuse them how
about that is there a responsibility for
that
no [ __ ] responsibility i'm sorry for
the language it's just this is
everything that's wrong with our country
this broad right here taking her
vacation to cackle in dc is everything
wrong with america
want to go back to it
go back to it
they come from families with incest
issues
sexual abuse issues no it's less than
it's less than half percent
of them they end up being
so like in a very damaged
situation overall so that one percent of
rape and incest abortions that happens
about one percent that's where abortions
come from is raven incest if we ban or
if we allow that he said that's cool if
you were raped or it's an incestual
thing yes you can get an abortion can we
ban the rest of it you know i'm going to
let you find someone to talk about
tell her
tell her you're going to go look for
someone rational
is to
come out
and show that
women
are second-class citizens now and that's
a shameful issue that's why i'm here
you're a shameful lady well
tell her you think tell her she's
participating in a
yeah let's do it and let's keep rolling
um so once they get set up ginger snap
we'll keep our camera rolling so we can
get you both going what's your name
connie
try and uh
try and froth her up before that if
you're going to do it together there
lane so that people can really
i am from texas
all right let's see
you guys
all right we'll check back in uh just
let me know as soon as they start
getting set up and who did he say he was
with what local uh dc
some local dc channel dc some local dc
channel well yeah somebody see if we can
local dc channel is about to go national
that woman ah women are second class
citizens because there's no answer this
really is the problem no accountability
women you are better than this
do you know who's better than this
every woman
before the modern abortion movement
who
if they had a child let's say that they
didn't plan for
raise them
and love them yeah that's a better
person than someone who aborts them
don't care if you look i'm getting away
from the idea of it oh being god
dividing the law and packing the courts
that's a better human being
okay
you're worse if you believe that you
aren't responsible think about every
answer well what if they're poor is
there any responsibility for that
that's economic circumstances
okay and then they'll neglect the child
is there any responsibility for that
hey i know people who were poor
who had children
and didn't neglect their child
you know who was one of them you know
abraham lincoln
you know who claims it was one of them
doesn't really fully check out barack
obama
right
there are a lot of people you're saying
it's not your response so if you're if
the woman is poor she can't be held
responsible
for not being cruel
women you're better than that
if she didn't plan for it well first off
there should be accountability in
planning for it
if she didn't plan for it she can't be
expected to deal with curveballs of life
you're not accountable for that
if then the baby's born
she can't be responsible for paying for
are you not accountable for that
when they say codify roe v wade what
they mean is codify
women reaping the financial benefits
from the taxpayer and from the male
who has helped create this life
benefiting from that without any
accountability that's what it is yeah
that's what it is you either have to
allow it has to be a joint decision
an abortion or keeping the life or you
forfeit alimony sorry you forfeit child
support
and by the way i think a guy
who would have a child and not pay child
support probably not a great guy
just to be clear
i hate that we have to have that
mandated because i think you should
support your children now i understand a
man who gets screwed by a woman who
leaves him
takes a lot of his stuff and then also
racks up a child support but i
understand the problem with child
support that right now the way it exists
it doesn't necessarily have to go to the
child i get all that believe me i
understand all that
that's not what i'm talking about right
now
i'm saying that a good man should want
to raise and support those children yeah
a good woman should as well regardless
of whether she's poor or rich it doesn't
matter you have student debt you don't
have student debt
you have a child in your life
grow up exactly
i i'm a little surprised though that
we're going back to my body my choice
especially given the vaccination
mandates that we saw right i'm so
surprised that it's a private health
decision between a doctor and don't come
to me and blow my nose yeah i i
i thought that was done i thought that
argument could never be used again
because these were the same people that
were pushing that you had to be
forcefully vaccinated to be able to do
anything in life
right in other countries it was
literally to go to work to own a
business to get out of your house any of
that stuff a little surprised we're
going back to that argument but here's
the other thing in high school
i had sex with my girlfriend before
marriage
i was i was already offered a
scholarship to the university of notre
dame i'd already accepted that
scholarship she came to me and said hey
i'm late
and it scared the hell out of me as a 17
18 year old kid i think it was 18 at the
time
and i was just like oh my gosh my life
may have just changed and i'm not saying
this
to toot my own horn or anything
i am saying this because this is how the
conversation should go
you're a man you made a choice yep
i told her
okay if you're pregnant i'll go to a
local college
and that's exactly what i was gonna do
that
wouldn't have ruined my life it would
have been different right
i would still be able to go to a
university that was great and that was
close to where i was so that i could
take responsibility for the decision
remember
decision that i made
but right now what people are telling
you is
athlete comes to you and says no no no
i've got a career ahead of me i've got
an nfl contract potentially i've got a
chance to play one of the best
universities know you have to abort yeah
you have to abort that child because you
can't ruin my life that's what they
would say this allows a tremendous
backdoor for abusive men towards yeah
that's what i understand you don't think
that a lot you don't think that men who
think they can have an out
won't try and gaslight the woman
won't try and convince her that she
doesn't want to have that child won't
try and pressure that woman
it's far easier to pressure a woman into
an abortion
than it would be especially if you're in
a state where it says we have that child
than it is to say all right let's do the
right thing
raise this kid there are far more men
out there who would rather you have an
abortion after an accident yeah and i'm
willing to bet that there are a lot of
women who are pressured into those
abortions even though the man has no say
in it right
so you have to think of the unintended
consequences by the way that brought who
we uh interviewed was from massachusetts
massachusetts i always have a problem
saying that it's difficult their laws uh
restrict abortion at 24 weeks
and it generally requires that one
parent or guardian or a judge can send
to a minor's abortion if the young
person is under 16. so uh a 17 year old
uh can have or 16 year old seems like
can have an abortion massachusetts at 24
weeks which is
up two is that
six and a half twenty four out of forty
whatever it's a little over halfway
right that's over half yeah halfway so
over halfway
i think what the earliest the earliest
premier now has been board is 21 weeks
22 weeks yeah or something yeah because
of modern technology you know putting an
incubator but still so in other words
the viability argument goes out so a 16
year old hey can have a 24 week abortion
in massachusetts
i've lost my rights and i've never even
understood the viability argument i
understand it's like hey if i take away
life support from this child it can't
survive so therefore i should be able to
kill it a 16 year old can kill a 24 week
old baby that's not enough that's not
enough
you think you're under the thumb of
oppressive men
for crying out loud where does
accountability does it kick in at week
26
that's why they don't want to answer
they're complaining that in
massachusetts
abortion at 24 weeks for a 16 year old
is a violation
of constitutional rights
this is where you pull the sling it's a
violation of a woman's constitutional
rights i read the bible i ain't read all
of it but i read a good deal of it
those stories you and mom told me
they ain't in there
constitution you can put it on a page if
you single space it
unbelievable
unbelievable all right does gingersnap
is he doing the local dc hit yet
we got disconnected but i think i found
their live stream oh they're they're on
the delay because i saw the guy that
reached out to him and now they're in a
it's a standby for stream oh okay oh
that's interesting and what what is the
name of their live stream uh dcw50 dcw50
do they have chat enabled there
no
there's no way for people to comment or
rate it
because i was going to say if you're
watching right now you can go over there
and you know leave some chat
by the way i want to if i can read this
senator mansion's uh got a quote this is
what it is oh there you go like this
yeah they were just showing him where it
said standing by for stream and never
sweating oh
well let l let gingersnap know to let it
rip i hope he goes on with that woman
yes absolutely so senator manchin i
trusted justice gorsuch gorsuch goss and
justice cavanaugh when they testified
under oath that they also believed roe v
wade was settled legal precedent and i'm
an alarm they chose to reject the
stability the ruling has provided one it
didn't provide stability it basically
just allowed 800 000 plus people to be
killed every single year and what they
said was true
this case has been decided
courts don't
give you an opinion on cases typically
until the case comes before them right
so they can say hey i understand that
that's the precedent that's been set
but they can also hear a case and go you
know what
we made a mistake do you never want the
court to overturn anything because if if
that were the case i think right now
there would be a lot of people
disenfranchised in this country still if
the court never overturns precedent
sometimes it happens where you go you
know what we made a mistake
yeah you know and this actually brings
me to uh i want to talk about because
we're going to have more information
coming out today about this the opinions
of dissenting opinions so yesterday was
the concealed carry law and
i didn't have that much time obviously
to go through it because it happened
while we were live on air but then i did
go home and i did read the opinions
and
what stuck out to me
were a couple of things first off sort
of like roe v wade if you look at it
here today or sorry uh
uh dobbs jackson
um it's not how it's been represented
there were actually some issues that
were very alarming
to me from uh
kavanaugh
in his danish interpretation of the
second amendment but what also stood out
to me
is the dissenting opinions on that so
kind of like i talked about in the past
heller versus dc this was the right
basically determining that private
citizens have the right to own firearms
if that one went the other way you
wouldn't have any right to own firearms
doesn't matter what kind of firearm
shotgun hunting rifle handgun revolver
nothing
the dissenting opinion said according to
our interpretation of the constitution
uh
regulated militia doesn't mean the
citizens of this country that private
citizens have no right to own firearms i
always say that sensing opinions are
just as important okay
um and in this case with the new york
law
what's so telling is none of them from
what i was reading cited the
constitution
they're not interested in it
they really aren't so let me read you
some quotes here this is from an msn
article
in a descent joined by his liberal
colleagues justice stephen breyer
focused on the toll taken by gun
violence and you can read this in the
bill since the start of this year alone
2022 there have already been 277
reported mass shootings an average of
more than one per day
that could not be less relevant to the
constitutionality right
it says backers of the new york's law
new york's law had argued that striking
it down would ultimately lead to more
guns in the streets and higher rates of
violent crime the decision comes at a
time when gun violence is already on the
rise during the coronavirus pandemic
uh has spiked anew that was also great
there in the article yes it spiked anew
there's no care about constitutionality
there have been there have been more
deaths there have been more people using
guns
does the constitution say they have the
right to own guns
there have been more people saying
horribly offensive things i can't
believe it
does the constitution say they have the
right to say horrible things you have
one side saying constitution says right
to keep and bear arms and by the way
every able-bodied american is a part of
the militia that's how it's recognized
oh
good or bad and by the way it's mostly
good again two to three million
defensive uses of firearms per year
versus tens of thousands
of acts of violence committed with
firearms not including suicides mostly
gangs mostly gang violence so it's
mostly good
but that doesn't matter what the
constitution hey guess what
you do have neo-nazis
very few
you do have racists who use speech
and by the way that includes black
racists like farrakhan
just to be clear you do have racists who
use horrible speech to breed
anti-semitism or you know for example in
the black community anti-asian hatred
where we've seen a spike in hate crimes
you do have some speech out there that's
pretty terrible you know what else every
single major civil rights advancement
came through
speed some of it through sitting rosa
parks but i'm pretty sure she spoke
while she was sitting my point is this
speech is the only way
allowing freedom
absolute freedom of speech the first
amendment is the only way for good ideas
to commit bad ideas just as surely
allowing absolute freedom of law abiding
americans to own firearms is the only
way to allow
law-abiding americans to protect
themselves from the evil that exists in
this world you can never do away with
evil in this world
you can't
the best you can do
is afford the good
the right to to die to protect
themselves against it the right to fight
back against it that's all you can do so
this is really important we have the
references available at earthquaker.com
it's just interesting to me that
yesterday
the opposition was not based at all on
constitutionality no not at all from the
justices from the justices the opposing
the dissenting justices it is very
important that you read the dissenting
opinions
to see just how close you were yeah to
some really messed up stuff well and to
understand how they approach the
constitution it it goes to their whims
they can go oh well we had a lot of a
lot of shootings and so therefore we
need to change it that that's not how
this works at all and that's what you
said but when they said we're going to
go based on the text and based on
history
and based on the kind of the precedent
that's been set with this and how people
understood this racially
that was exactly the way that it was
supposed to be interpreted and then any
changes could be made through a
different process let's watch cnn
because they just brought up the
clarence thomas issue and i think
they're trying to say that he wants to
kill all the gays
so steve ledeck if i wanted to challenge
same-sex marriage if i want to challenge
the right to contraception uh i'm either
in court today or tomorrow right
thinking this court might give me you
know in a year or two i'm not going to
give you a pass
so john i mean obviously there's one
step before that which is we would need
to see states presumably red states
adopting laws that go after these
precedents but that's not a hypothetical
i mean we know there are legislators in
mississippi and idaho for example who
want to introduce legislation to
restrict abortion and you know john
jessica read the blind from alito's
about how this is limited
well i think the dissent also has a
pretty good response on this which is
that the analysis is not limited to
abortion the notion that the
constitution doesn't protect rights
unless they're deeply rooted in our
traditions that's not limited to
abortion so what the joint descent said
we didn't say deeply rooted in
traditions i'm talking about clarence
thomas said deeply rooted in the
constitution
constitutional rights are under threat
it's one or the other and john it's not
hard to imagine red states moving
quickly to try to push the envelope on
these other rights we're already seeing
it that we're already seeing it and joan
where no no no no no no you can't just
say that we're already seeing it you
quoted something about abortion which is
what we're specifically talking about
you can't say they're going after
same-sex marriage you can't say that
they're going after the right to
contraception and they go yeah we're
already seeing it with abortion yeah by
the way i think that states should have
the right to regulate same-sex marriage
you know why because states have
different divorce laws
state issue oh it's no fault divorce
which by the way means that in many of
these states a woman cheats on you she
leaves she takes half
so it's not no fault it's the fault of
the man
and that's why look you can argue until
you're blue in the face
even the women who separate yourself
from promise well she is entitled to 40
40 of young men don't want to get
married
thins out the hurt a little bit what do
you what do you want
do you want to have do you want to be
able to get married
or do you want to be living husty for
the rest of your life there's gonna have
to be a compromise there need to be
changes to to marital laws and i'm not
even talking about same-sex marriage
talking about divorce laws talking about
alimony laws talking about child support
laws men now don't want to get married
it's a raw deal for a lot of them and
i'm not on board
with the the men's rights activists who
believe that they shouldn't be held
accountable for any certainly not on
board with the pickup culture the idea
of one night stands not at all but i am
saying that there does need to be a give
and take to all legal contracts that's
not the case in many of these no fault
divorce states so i don't know why it's
outlandish to say well this state can
make it no fault and this state can say
that if you cheat you forfeit your right
to the division of property
and states can't say by the way these
are the qualifications for marriage
namely a man and a woman i i don't know
again legally you may not like it
but it seems to me that it should be a
state issue
i want the state as uninvolved in
marriage as possible yes
will you know i i i honestly
it's a covenant
as a christian it's a covenant between
you
your wife or your husband and god
it didn't say and thou shalt go to the
courthouse and give half
thou shalt have
thou shalt have joint ally bank accounts
you know i mean i just it ends up
unfortunately it's destroyed the
institution of marriage for young
christian men how many how many chats do
we get how many emails do we get and
this there's there hasn't been a show
that's been more pro-institution of
marriage than this program and how many
messages do we get from young christian
men going like yeah you know i real but
i'm really afraid to do this because i
live in a state where even if she cheats
on me and she leaves i have to pay half
and i have to pay alimony we go like
i get it it's a raw deal where i'm
almost at the point of advocating
you get married in the church as a
covenant
and just ignore the state at that point
because you guys should be together
because you make a covenant before god
which should be stronger than the state
it shouldn't be about property and tax
benefits unfortunately i understand why
it is
because we wanted to create a nuclear
family as a building block for society
here but i don't understand you know
people act as though it's this travesty
if states can determine all kinds of
marital laws why can't states determine
they can determine what qualifies for a
marriage in many other facets they can
say well you can't marry someone why
because you're already married so you
can't marry a second one you say okay
that's fine they can say hey well you
can't you can't take half why because
you cheated so you can't you don't get
to divide half at this point okay but
then another state says i don't care i
should cheat it she she can take half or
he can take half if she's a primary
earner
they can do that why can't they say well
you can't get married why because you
both have dicks
okay
your rules missouri
well and i think what you would find is
that most people would say look i may
not approve of what you're doing i may
not like that but i want to make sure
that in the state's eyes you're treated
the same as i am right most people would
be willing to say that right now and and
honestly people forget in the debate
most people before same-sex marriage was
legalized
were saying that right they were saying
civil unions do something that in the
states eyes make sure that there are
rights to those people that are afforded
that are the same rights that i get
that's what elton john said
elton john agreed with rush limbaugh
saying civil unions not the marriage
issue and marriage should be a church
issue it always was a church issue
you want to trample our rights
a 16 year old can only have an abortion
up until 24 weeks
come on now
whereas you know what the right is
saying you want oh
a state can say that they can restrict
an abortion after a heartbeat uh when
conservatives are saying hey
you don't have the right to tell me that
i cannot protect myself and my family
because the document says you can't
one's whining for a right that doesn't
exist and one's saying get your [ __ ]
together i'm gonna do it anyway
it's amazing it's a it's the same people
who will who will send leah thomas a
trophy yeah and the uh i forgot her name
the girl who was interviewed yesterday
she tied her they go oh that's the
beautiful woman is leah thomas you call
b you call weird looking at best
beautiful and then you call beautiful
third place when it was a tie and what
you call
a via a violation of rights is actually
constitutional right what you call a
constitutional right isn't in there
you're going to love some wording that
to one of your favorite governors who do
you think i'm talking about it better
not be news him no no oh no whitmer
whitmer oh careful hold on careful
hold on a second wait
you need a second you need some booze or
something take a swig actually honestly
with my throat
a little bit that'll help okay just just
a little swig there you go by the way
don't think i don't haven't noticed that
this was an entire bottle of wild turkey
like a week ago guys that was not me but
it was me um
we're not waiting for a supreme court
decision this is 20 hours ago right so
yeah i tweeted better but yeah i'm
taking action hold on you'll like these
words i'm taking action and fighting
like hell
wait
i thought fight like hell was
insurrection talk let's send her a shirt
yeah that's under a shirt and they send
her a shirt that says fight like hell
yeah but she won't like the person who's
on it because he's the guy who was part
of the group that wrote the documents
that you hate right you can go buy the
shirt at louder is it little credit shop
i don't think she's calling for an
insurrection by the way two days earlier
she said menstruating persons she did
which is the funniest thing i've heard
i'm gonna protect abortion rights for
any has there ever been
a male
transgender meaning male who claims he's
a female has there ever been
a successful abortion there have
probably been you know unsuccessful
abortions where he jammed a coat hanger
in his taint but have there ever been
board medically qualifies an abortion
for a man who identifies as a woman has
it ever happened trick question no yeah
here's i know the answer here's another
fun thing that you're going to hear
you're going to hear this a lot right
i've heard this from a lot of people
robert reich one person i tend to hate a
lot gerald's favorite robert third right
this guy has way too many people
listening to him he needs to be brought
down a notch five of nine supreme court
justices were appointed by gop
presidents who entered office without
even winning the popular vote just keep
your eye on that because are you saying
that they're illegitimate presidents
that didn't win the popular vote are you
saying that that was
that makes them illegitimate and that
five of the nine justices that are on
the court right now were appointed by
these guys and that's isn't that guy an
nyu professor no no he is uh actually at
well what is west coast
uh berkeley oh berkeley berkeley
berkeley sorry it's that other [ __ ]
that you should never attend he's an
economist you know
former put on that planet to make
astrologers look intelligent i stole
that totally stole that
all right let's see what this guy's
talking about here on cnn manu raju she
was one of the decisive votes here and
she just put out a statement john in
which he said that the decisions is
inconsistent with what justices gorsuch
and kavanaugh said in their testimony
and in their minds
she goes on to say she's very
disappointed by this ruling joe manchin
also a key vote to confirm brett
kavanaugh said similar inconsistent with
what kavanaugh and gorsuch had said to
them privately about allowing this
president to to be upheld now
nevertheless democrats are vowing to
make this an issue come november of
course because it's the only issue so
what are they going to do they're going
to lie to you they're going to lie to
you and say that abortion has now been
banned across the country when it has
not
you most likely have zero differences
right now in your state
maybe there will be some changes you can
go to another state they want to make
this an issue because they cannot
discuss any genuine let me ask and i
want you to be objective you guys can
comment below when you're watching this
in the archive or
we'll take some chats
i've tried to think of this
for the average american listening
watching if you're
what can a democrat argue has improved
is there anything honestly i'm trying to
think okay the economy obviously not
inflation obviously not
um crime obviously not
america's standing in the world you may
say peop you didn't like donald trump
but obviously come on after afghanistan
come on i mean
likes us a lot right now yeah ukraine
likes us a lot they like everybody right
now international policy no obviously
not no
um division right he was going to unite
america obviously not build back better
how's that going build back better
obviously
what else can they argue if they don't
just go to the abortion issue and lie to
you i i can't think of anything and i
try to look at it objectively
i know they try and say we have a
booming economy but the poll after pull
after poll shows that people don't
believe them well and maybe people don't
believe we have clip c people don't
believe jean-pierre
the white house uh to be clear will the
president accept this decision because
of reasons like this even if he
disagrees with it
it's going to come from the supreme
court so it's going to be a decision
that uh we're certainly are going to
respond to uh so i'll leave it at me
it's just like any other supreme court
decision just like the one that they did
today on guns
he's supposed to speak soon by the way
biden the bigotry of low expectations
yeah
i like the one on guns and stuff what
what
okay you know all right and stuff well
here's here's kind of an interesting
thing too um
i i i don't want to steal somebody's
stuff but you see stuff on twitter all
the time right it's like you know just
joking around about this stuff but it's
like i haven't seen democrats this mad
since we freed the slaves that that
keeps popping yeah
it's like but i love that it's just
taking credit for something that
republicans absolutely 100 did
but it was interesting to me too that
you have politicians of all people on
the planet
saying they said something that they
spun
when they came before the hearing they
said something i thought i thought it
was settled it was like yeah it's
settled but that means you're going to
vote for it no it just means it's
settled until we hear another case
you're a politician you do this for a
living you lie to constituencies for a
living yes and now you're calling out
somebody who actually spoke truthfully
but just not in the way you wanted it to
be are you serious that's your reason
for saying oh if i didn't know this
i would have voted differently well
again it's just
these these people are you not held
accountable for your vote no
it just it really does we have that is
the fundamental problem is we have a a
problem of a complete lack of
accountability in this country
that's where people like jordan peterson
jocko willink and some of these other
probably people who would be considered
more radical on youtube or wherever
wherever they're broadcasting tick-tock
could find some common ground i think a
lot of people are tired of the complete
lack of accountability and so we're all
supposed to go on with it
let me see if i can find the alyssa
milano stuff just if you guys are
looking for a laugh is that still in
here yeah i saw it in there yeah all
right hold on a second you guys want to
laugh
yes i definitely do all right is she
going to wear another mask that she
crocheted
all right alyssa milano okay
that's the best listen milano by the way
having a rough go since charmed
it's
even that was a rough go the 90s it was
not aptly named luis milano i don't
think milano that charming silver
tongued fox cursed so yes
hexed
so today's supreme court ruling
overturning roe v wade will have deadly
consequences hold on a second oh boy
yeah yeah yeah
deadly consequences
deadly con okay
here's the irony pre-alert
the next part is the full irony alert
with the harm falling hardest on people
of color who already face
disproportionate discrimination in our
country
and grapple with a severe maternal
mortality crisis
it's borderline a genocide against black
americans by design if you look at the
history of margaret sanger she didn't
just by the way not boring she didn't
just set up in poor areas no she didn't
set up in poor white areas she
specifically said poor urban black areas
she was a eugenicist it's going to have
deadly consequences particularly the
people of color well hold on a second
people of color in this country and i
feel racist saying people of color
honestly that's the term black people in
this country
are the most likely to have an abortion
because you
have sold them on a bill of goods that
they have subsequently found out isn't
true that it's the way out and for
crying out loud sherry shepard when she
was on the view she talked about
you know she was she was taking uh
morning after pills like they were m m's
she said she had four abortions
gosh classy like reagan's jelly bean
change dish by the way i do have a
question are you saying that people of
color or black people are
are more incapable
except for better pregnancy is that what
she's saying right here it gets better
okay let's keep going
banning abortion will disproportionately
impact people of color okay
lgbtq plus communities i'm sorry
okay hold on a second let me let me
break down because there's so much to
get to let me break this down lgbtq plus
we're gonna have to ignore the plus well
we have to get rid of the l and the g
because it won't happen let's go through
it okay this will disproportionately
impact
lesbians
[Applause]
less than heterosexual there you go
there you go they're only getting half
the reps in
trans
wrong
but part of the trend
queer questioning depending who you ask
doesn't really mean anything they
clearly would be affected less why
because too broad scissoring will never
run into the problem of an unplanned
pregnancy the g's
don't abort butt babies
the bees only have 50 percent
of the reps in that could result in an
unplanned pregnancy the t's are out of
their mind if they're trying to get
abortions done
and the cues
don't mean anything at this point
honestly i don't even know how they're
included maybe they are
disproportionately affected depending on
what it means i'll give you that one
maybe they're more promiscuous than
those yes yes maybe yeah yeah it could
be
that says people struggling to make ends
meet oh come on young people and those
living in rural areas what cause the
farm girl can't say no what are you
talking about here
is that i don't know doesn't need to say
no she's a shotgun you poor people can't
have kids poor people can't make good
life decisions are you saying that poor
people are mentally incapable of saying
sex bad it
this is an actual
these words that i'm about to read
were actually written in the sequence
i'm about to read them
to form the phrase that you are about to
hear
from melissa milano
banning abortion is about controlling
women and trans men
ridiculous
yeah i'm pretty sure that that's what
clarence thomas was thinking yeah saying
how can i mess with some how can i live
with some trans men today just really
really mess with their mind let me stir
[ __ ] up i know
trans men what do they care about most
something that they cannot perform on
themselves is this a penis on my diet
cocaine is this a penis oh my dad
cocaine can somebody chop off their
penis and put it on my dad cocaine they
speak english and trans man
then she says
it's about white supremacy the
patriarchy and misogyny it's a sad day
for america uh
really why do you think so little of
women
yeah and you think far too much of of
the the trends that you think they can
get pregnant yeah white supremacy a
black judge voted for this uh a
patriarchy a woman voted for this i
think you've got issues with your theory
come on this isn't us trying to control
anything it's trying to save lives by
the way i just want to do some quick
math if i gave you a hypothetical
situation right good people that you're
defending
i can say hey it's it's possible that
two thousand people could die from this
okay your decision one way you get two
options possible this way door number a
possible two thousand people could die
guaranteed in door number two door b
eight hundred thousand people will die
per year which one do you choose
guaranteed eight hundred thousand plus
are gonna die every single year yeah
option two option one maybe two thousand
maybe ten thousand maybe fifteen
thousand people are going to die but in
option one but it's amazing
well i guess especially it would
especially if without any other context
but if the 2000 people who die are
involved in an attempted murder at that
point well and they're not pedophiles
right either so that's if they're killed
you know what i would still have to say
if i have to pick i would go
i would go with a 2000. you go yeah so
whatever
that's what we're talking about right
now they're making the argument that
women may die i don't want women to die
nobody does but i also by the way you're
being very generous with the argument of
2000 eight i know eight hundred thousand
plus per year are guaranteed
to die yeah how many of them will okay
if somebody's out there fact-checking me
saying there's been a lower year six
hundred thousand plus how many since roe
v weighed 35 40 45 million people yeah
stalin wouldn't know what to do but you
know what they say and this is why it's
evil they say well guess what our social
welfare system can't handle it
you don't need the social social welfare
system to handle it if people are held
accountable if the ex you know what i
have found
in employing many people
and speaking to many people by the way
you watching right now that
you have some who won't
but the expectations you set
are almost universally
almost it's almost always the most
important metric and how somebody else
performs or behaves
the expectations you set
the expectations that you set as a
society
the expectations that you set in a
relationship
it's almost always the most important
contributing factor if you expect
someone to be sexually responsible and
let them know beforehand that there are
consequences more will be if you expect
someone whether they are rich or poor
to not be abusive
they are less likely to be abusive
if you expect women to be incapable
of being held responsible for any and
all of their decisions
they won't hold themselves responsible
and you're also letting men off the hook
in a lot of ways
this is just i mean if you don't
understand the overarching issue here
what kind of a society do you want to do
you really want to live in a society
where half of them have no and by the
way it's not just this is the same issue
with the black lives matter riots
half this country was not held
accountable for rioting for looting and
not only that but after that stealing
in san francisco right if you're
stealing less than was it 900 something
dollars at a walgreens how many videos
have we shown you laughing it is
hysterical but
why because they know the expectations
we're not gonna do anything we're not
gonna do anything if you steal this so
i'll do it i think the guy that was
interviewing lane is talking right now
live on their channel all right let's
see who this man is maybe he just
abandoned lane
gingersnap for almost 50 years we're
talking about roe versus wade they were
just talking about the shameful lady
that really okay can we bring it up a
layer of federal protection if you will
of abortion across america that was
completely wiped away today and now the
baton is being passed back to the state
legislatures so that way you know
governors and state delegates and state
senators can make that decision on their
own and their respective you know
jurisdiction their respective state the
50 states of uh of i think this guy's
auditioning for a norelco
just moments before we came live with
you randy we spoke with somebody who is
staunchly opposed to abortion and
somebody who is staunchly
after the news that broke today we will
have that conversation later on in our
newscasts throughout
the tune for that but right now
reporting from i was doing a stand up
well you know what let's go to a
gingersnap and ask him how it went so he
can tell us how it actually went and
then in real time you can watch and see
how they presented on their local news
that'll be interesting to see
why are they waiting why didn't they
just stream it live right yeah they
probably stuff was said that they're
like yeah we can't say that we can't say
that yeah like they never went back to
that woman on cnn because she was making
good points right exactly yeah i'm
willing to bet that it is not the uh the
entire context of the conversation and
this is the value of doing it without a
net you guys are seeing this this is all
live we have someone there on the ground
uh next time we'll definitely have a
better connection sorry this is kind of
the best we could do last minute but a
lot of credit dot com slash mug club
enter in the promo code save scotus you
get 20 off uh monday through thursday 10
a.m eastern is when we usually do the
show
this is just kind of a special live
stream
a day that will live in infamy said
shaking elizabeth warren
yeah we got the hashtag
i want to put her happy pills bottle in
her hand so she can be used like a
moroccan
and i don't think she has parkinson's i
just think she has rage
she's just constantly it's like it's
like it's like
the the the nagging
misery just trying to escape her body
like palpatine like it's gonna be like
electrical shocks of just nagging
bitchiness you know her husband every
time that he hears like hey sweetie just
you know that he just his heart just
goes like
the kind of guy who would if he finds
himself in a coma he would fake
remaining in that coma if he woke up and
saw elizabeth warren's face he was just
like
how long until uh he gets a dui and goes
to jail
just to escape maybe not go to jail oh
uh pelosi's husband didn't go to jail i
don't believe that he went to jail no
i'm not sure that he went to jail but
elizabeth warren's husband probably
won't uh get a dui he'll probably wrap
his car around a tree wow yeah that's
the way he wants to go i guess like oh
my god
there was a brick on the accelerator
[Laughter]
no stopping that one he just he just
tapes a poster of elizabeth warren on
his back window so that if he looks back
that's just what he sees
uh sure why not yeah let me grab a
little bit of a what do you got there
he's got uh he's got some energy drinks
here you want some good no i'm good
are they saying we're good we should
keep going yeah
all right sorry keep going for a little
bit i mean obviously at some point well
i don't you missed it they just said
they're going to go back to lane oh are
they yeah so they said they need to edit
it so what we want to do is get ginger
snap on yeah him inform us of of what
the conversation actually yeah what it
transpired i know beto has come out and
issued a statement about this if we can
pull that up i know abbott and beto have
both issued kind of counter what did he
kick flip his way into a woman's uterus
basically the only tweet that i see this
may not be the statement we will
overcome this decision in texas by
winning political power
okay
he's going to perform
he's going to perform his famous 180
snatch flip yeah snatch flip to click
grind so elect me and i'll you know i'll
change all that there is a video online
that maybe we want to go to i have no
idea the content 42 minutes ago the this
moment demands action
do you want to pull that up on from his
sure yeah i'm going to put does anyone
want anyone want the half this energy
drink usually gingersnap is the one who
drinks the half the energy drinker all
right hold on sorry i'm gonna go put
this in that cup i'm just gonna put this
i'll take it you want to take it oh wait
a second i'm sick oh that's uh no wait i
poured it i didn't drink from here okay
i'll tell you okay but lick it just to
be safe yeah yeah
do we have the ability to pull up the uh
the beto thing
oh yeah the oh this moment demands
action yeah that's the tweet that he uh
it's governor candidate texas
he's a candidate stephen
for getting his butt kicked third time
yeah i got it right here celebrate that
okay go ahead no i can't go right now
i meant him go ahead sorry all right
because when it's only you on screen we
lose it really is rough
the supreme court has overruled roe
versus wade this is devastating to the
minute long across this country but
nowhere more so than the state of texas
whose trigger law will go into effect we
have biden let's pause this let's pause
let's pause this [ __ ] boy let's go to
former vice president joe biden let's
see what he says and if he respects the
law of the land or
sedition constitutes a right from the
american people
that it already recognized
they didn't limit it they simply took it
away
that's never been done to a right so
important to so many americans take it
away
they give it to the states
and for the country fifty years ago roe
v wade
was decided and has been the longest you
said you were gonna be there joey
landmark case protected woman's right to
choose
her right to make intensely personal
decisions with their doctor
free from entertainment interference of
politics i'm sorry what
to reaffirm basic principles of equality
that women have the power to control
their own destiny hey and a reinforced
intensely personal that's obama's
statement right
the most intensely personal decision
yeah joe biden bring up the obama
twitter
yeah
they all want to talk about a manchurian
candidate it's literally from the obama
twitter statement the most intensely
personal decision
someone can make those were his exact
words right now as vice president now as
president united states
i've studied this case carefully
he's got shields supreme court
confirmations than anyone today
where this case was always discussed
i believe roe v wade was the correct
decision
as a matter of constitutional law and
application of the fundamental right to
privacy and liberty and matters of
family and personal autonomy
it was a decision
on a complex matter
that drew a careful balance between a
woman's right to choose
earlier in her pregnancy
and the state's ability to regulate
later in her pregnancy
no mention of their life broad national
consensus yeah the most americans of
faith
and backgrounds found acceptable
wrong
even ruth bader ginsburg said it was bad
law americans today
and it was a constitutional principle
upheld
by justices appointed by democrat
and republican presidents alike they
were white guys roe v wade was a 7-2
decision
written by a justice appointed by a
republican president richard nixon
in the five decades that followed roe v
wade just as important science advances
from eisenhower
nixon reagan
george w bush
were among the justices who voted to
uphold the principles set forth in roe v
wade and 65 plus million
donald trump
were the core of today's decision to
upend the scales of justice and
eliminate a fundamental right
for women in this country newly elected
presidents who had the right to appoint
justices you just don't like it this
decision is a culmination of a
deliberate effort over decades careful
upset
balance of our law
oh boy it's a realization oh boy here
comes
error by the supreme court in my view
the court has done what it has never
done before
expressly take away a curse
right
it is so fundamental
to so many americans that it wasn't he
just gave license right now this just
gave license to the riots that you are
going to see and the violence that you
are going to see the most extremists
have for the first time stripped you of
a constitutional right if that is not a
justification to violence which we are
already seeing that is so much worse
than fight like hell
that is so much worse than fight like
hell he just gave you license to go hog
wild churches crisis pregnancy centers
families with pro-life bumper stickers
protect your kin
the child the consequence
it just it just stuns me
so extreme the doctors will be
criminalized for fulfilling their duty
to care
i thought it was first do not harm what
about the harm of the life that you're
ending
i love how he just ignores by the way
says it was 50 years ago
at one point black people weren't
considered the same as a white person
and then through often the case advance
through actual progress we said when
there's equal rights
hey we've advanced we've advanced
medically in fact you do realize that
right we didn't have the same technology
to recognize a heartbeat to recognize
genetic material unique genetic code we
know that now we know everything that i
am
everything that gerald is everything
that tool man is everything in token now
one is everything that that keagan is
who's in here because uh uh yakuza had a
doctor's appointment everything that we
are
was already there
at the point where they could have an
abortion that genetic code
that determined who we are
i was not something else
how i would grow when i would grow what
my hair would look like what color eyes
i would have to my skin texture
to the fact that i get worked up and
some of you find it mild entertaining so
i'm able to make a living
all of that genetic material was there
we know that now we didn't know that
then
this fall
must elect more senators representatives
who will codify
a woman's right to choose in the federal
law once again
elect more state leaders to protect this
right at the local level
we need to restore the protections of
roe
as law of the land we need to elect
officials who will do that
this fall roe is on the ballot
they're loving this personal freedoms
are on the ballot they are loving it the
right to privacy it needs to be met
liberty equality
they're all on the ballot
forget everybody
i will do all of my power to protect a
woman's right in states
where they will face the consequences of
today's decision
how well the court's decision cast a
dark shadow over a large swath of the
land many states in this country still
tell me you guys pulled that clip of him
copying obama i want to run them side by
side after
so
if a woman lives in a state that
restricts abortion
the supreme court's decision does not
prevent her from traveling from her home
state to the state that allows it that's
correct it does not prevent a doctor
i didn't i haven't seen everything in
the bill but i haven't seen that yet
uh research team guys you can tell me if
there's any restriction on people being
allowed to travel safely to another
state to seek care they need
my administration will defend that
bedrock right
if any state or local official high or
low
tries to interfere with a woman's
exercise and her basic right to travel i
will do everything in my power
nobody's citing that right deeply
un-american attack that i know of do you
my administration
i think massachusetts actually had
something but it was a
executive order signed today by governor
charlie baker it prohibits extradition
to other states for violation of that
state's law yeah but i mean in the in
the thing so that means i think you guys
can explain that to me i think what it
means that if someone were to come into
your state and get an abortion
right that other states wouldn't be able
to punish you but he's right he's
creating that executive order so that it
implies that other states are going to
do that yeah
or severely restrict access to these
medications
or search the person's medicine cabinet
or control a woman's actions by tracking
data on her apps she uses are wrong and
extreme and out of touch good you
understand that having a vaccine
passport and tracking sick people is
wrong and it's not good joe biden
welcome
to the republican party
wrote to me and vice president harris
mispronounced go [ __ ] yourself
let's go brandon asking us to act to
protect access to care they say
by limiting access to these medicines
maternal mortality will climb in america
that's what they say
today i'm directing fetal mortality
what about baby mortality take steps
to ensure these critical medications are
available to the fullest extent possible
what critical medications and the
politicians abortively
interfere
in the decisions that should be made
between a woman and her doctor
and my administration remain vigilant
as the implications of this decision by
the way let's also think of that
language
her doctor
are you really getting your abortions
performed at your general practitioner
let's go a step further your regular ob
gyn
it's not your doctor
it's a merchant of death
those are the people who perform
abortions in this country let's be clear
about it it's not your doctor
women aren't having abortions performed
by doctors who know them which by the
way would be important understanding not
only their their personal health history
their psychiatric history
you have to seek out a merchant of death
who does that almost exclusively we say
it's her doctor like it's a general
family practitioner
to reconsider the right of marriage
equality nope the right of couples to
make their choices on contraception
that's a lie
this extremely dangerous path the court
is now taking us on
let me close the two points
oh better be able to count
i call on everyone no matter how deeply
they care about this decision
to keep all protests peaceful okay good
i'll give them peaceful peaceful
peaceful no intimidation well no trump
said the same thing trump said the exact
same thing
he's following trump threats
and tim and intimidation are not speech
we must stand against violence and how
much you prosecute that yeah how about
you say you're gonna use everything in
your power to prosecute those people so
i said you'll use everything in your
power to make sure women can travel
across state lines to kill babies right
now you just requested
pretty please don't be violent
so fundamental
i know so many women are now going to
face incredibly difficult situations of
not having sex i hear you
i support you of only having four
choices
abstinences motherhood adoption
contraception
oh the
the plight of the modern feminist woman
dignity
and the stability of the rule of law
yeah because there's nothing more
dignified than forceps up your snatch
with this decision
the conservative majority of the supreme
court shows how extreme it is
how far removed they are from the
majority that states
can create their own laws made the
united states
it is the final word deal with it my
administration will use all of its
appropriate lawful powers
but congress must act
good luck
with your vote wait are you saying that
the justices who were appointed by a
democratically elected president are
illegitimate
is that what you're saying joe biden i
just want to be clear because the people
elected donald trump right and donald
trump had the right to appoint these
justices are you saying that was
illegitimate
it can't be the final word that we will
go against this court i just want to
understand
are you saying that the the the the
people's representatives the elected
officials of texas are illegitimate
sounds like sedition to me help us out
sounds a whole lot more seditious if
that's a word then uh hey uh
check the voting records for that 165
000 vote flip that took place in 20
minutes in wayne county sounds a whole
lot more
like questioning the institutions than
just saying i don't know
there seems to be something fishy with
the poll workers in a pipe breaking i
would talk about voting machines being
you know open to attack but i would be
quoting hillary clinton and i would be
quoting democrats pre-2016
amy mediocre club yeah i wouldn't want
to do that jimmy carter i wouldn't want
to raise concerns about the legitimacy
of elections because i would be quoting
democrats right all right i don't want
to do or is it there was that film i
forgot what was called something uh
blockchain yeah that existed in uh it
was on
hbo where the guy literally hacked the
georgia dominion voting machines and
bitched about those machines in front of
them and in front of them do me a favor
you go vote for your candidate and he
flipped their votes and then afterwards
he said oh no no no it seems like they
fixed it when he was talking about the
20 20 people said how did they fix it
are they still using the same machines
yeah yeah but uh i wouldn't be able to
hack it now they're like well why don't
you let us try no no no go watch it go
watch blockchain the point is this i'm
not saying that i certainly can verify
all of these issues i'm not saying that
what i am saying is well before this
election
you had commissions on election
integrity jimmy carter elizabeth warren
amy klobuchar hillary clinton i believe
was involved in one capacity or another
you had documentaries that existed
where they were hacking dominion voting
machines so the idea that questioning it
is sedition whereas this man just said
that these
supreme court justices who by the way it
entirely went through a process
that has historical precedence
right it was yeah people elected a
president he appointed justices that's
how it works to say this is extreme
and i'll go against it also people elect
their own state representatives and they
have the right to make these decisions
to say i will do everything to stop them
i don't know that seems it seems a whole
lot more severe to me yeah it does so
put this in context with what we already
know right so
he's he's saying that right these guys
are illegitimate
he also is the same president who did
not ask his justice department to
enforce the law about protesting in
front of us a justice's home to try to
sway their opinion which has been going
on
since the memo was leaked in may yep
so what is he basically saying here
these guys are illegitimate
and you can kind of break the law and
we're not going to enforce it yeah
there's no protection can you imagine
being kavanaugh or amy coney barrett
right now or alito
or or anything hold on a second look at
cnn look they're literally using airpods
like us are they yeah we made it cool
do we do we have ginger snap by the way
uh no we're having skype issues oh okay
okay because ginger snap uh uh
uh yakuza just came in uh all right so
that's your name now casey after i saw
your tattoos
that's your new name yakuza it's
actually a badass name it is you should
hate it that way it'll stick yeah yeah
um it's the worst yes oh no so yakuza
just came in uh by the way how was your
doctor's appointment the guy with the
rubber glove was surprisingly gentle oh
nice
do you now have a vagina was the process
a success yeah i don't want to talk
about it by the way you may need to
change where you keep your spare keys oh
no that's a personal issue
i want to see a trump flag out here with
this because thank you trump did uh were
they able to pull that clip of biden
just saying that uh the exact quote from
obama's i don't know that anyone else
has caught this so i want to
read to you were they able to pull that
clip do they get it to us yeah they're
working on it now
so let me know when they have it because
i want to read the obama statement
right right there and then
show what joe biden just said because a
lot of people have suspected
suspected allegedly allegedly that
former vice president joe biden
is as former vice president joe biden
does
and by that i mean there's a reason that
i use the term former vice president joe
biden because that's what he is
respect the office yes respect the
office and he was just speaking live and
he said the exact
same
thing
word for word
that barack obama released
on twitter as a statement let me know
when we have it because i want to read
the obama statement and then have that
right next to it if you're watching
right now hit like
if you want us to do more of these
streams live as we experience this with
you yeah
hit like
share right because you're the only
thing that helps us through the youtube
algorithms and by that i mean all of you
combined to help us maybe get three
percent of what other average channels
get these days uh but not the ability to
make a living
no no that's zero percent zero yeah your
work does nothing for that but we love
you anyway great
do we have the clip
no i'm still getting it how are you
still getting it we just watched it live
by the way i bet what you'll see you'll
see that exact phrase so they've used
that phrase before right the most
intensely personal decision i haven't
heard that exact phrase used before i
have i have heard it before we can look
it up but i guarantee you whether that's
true or not you will hear it from every
single democrat now on the sunday shows
on every interview they give
they're going to try to use the most
like flowery language they can possibly
say
well they're circulating talking points
i think even clinton's uh
twitter tweet whatever she sent out was
very similar too did you guys see by the
way can we pull this up from yesterday
joe biden the card that he came out with
oh gosh with the instructions
you take your seat yeah yes you say your
is capitalized and that you is like what
because i know if i just said you take a
seat he was just going to go out and sit
with the press yeah he's going to grab a
chair he was going to chauncey gardner
that [ __ ]
it was like when bill bill cosby you
know back before he was a rapist he used
to talk about uh
he was like because when you have young
boys you have to
describe everything
and i cannot say go upstairs and take a
shower because it'll be standing
upstairs
fully clothed so what you have to do is
say go up the stairs
take off your clothes
go in through the shower
turn on the water
this was his bit and yes soap and that
is what they have to do with joe biden
that is exactly what we have to do with
joe
you shall take your seat
you shall not take the seat
of the press secretary that is not you
or the secretary of defense neither take
now the seat of cnbc correspondents the
seat being taken is that of your seat
and i guarantee you the seat that he
takes has the words your written on it
because he wouldn't understand potus the
seat of pro temp purim of the senate is
right
out good monty is there a take in your
seats your seat being the seats taken
i wonder i want some we got to be able
to read that we have to review oh yeah i
think the daily wire actually was the
one they did a zoom in and so they saw
what it said it said like take your seat
um what do i say you take your seat then
what does it say
you enter the roosevelt room and say
hello to participants
you take your seat yeah press enters you
give brief comments view is
parts there's a t in parentheses i don't
know why uh you ask liz shuler president
afl-cio a question and then we'll say
believe it you
you thank participants
don't forget the theater because that's
not written there it's like you asked a
question from afl-cio there's nothing
left
go [ __ ] yourselves
[Laughter]
you're supposed to say thank you oh you
should have told me i was just you know
i was riffing like jazz
cue cards are fine but can you just uh
can you just make it to where it doesn't
sound like he's a bumbling idiot like
you enter the room and thank people for
i mean
i'm sorry my language is a little salty
today because f's are easier than
anything in the back of my throat it's
true yeah
it's easier to think through that word
no just because my sore throat like l's
are hard oh for you and asian h's are
hard do we have that clip
from the speech that we just watched
struggle is real we check
no we don't have it yet
guys the speech we just watched it was
very early on in his speech they have it
they're just cutting it uh they're gonna
cut it just get sent to the time code we
can play it right there on the video we
don't need to cut it ah remember saying
send you the link and uh we can just
play the uh play the clip it was within
the first minute and a half
that is a faster way yeah
it doesn't have to be you know this is
one thing we're we're actually playing
jazz right here
uh
i'm trying to see if there's anything
else that we need to know that's been
going on with this bill can we go back
to beta's clip oh yeah you know what
play beethoven's clip while we're doing
that can can we not because uh i'd be
going back and forth because token allen
has to find that other clip
no i have betas up okay cool all right
okay let's play beto's clip that's one
minute of hilarity from beto
the supreme court has overruled roe
versus wade this is devastating to women
across this country but nowhere more so
than in the state of texas so they're
gonna say nowhere more
30 days from today meaning that abortion
will be illegal in the state of texas
with no exception for rape or incest
that's not the blank bill we have to
focus on the way in which we are going
to overcome this and ensure that every
texas woman speaking of incest your eyes
are pretty far apart her own body her
own health care and her own future the
only way to do this is to win political
power we must win on the night of
november 8th i need you
right now in this race with us so that i
can study somewhere other than
a single voter across the state of texas
and ensure that they understand what's
on the line it's a woman's right to
choose and it's the very lives of texas
women a state that leads much of the
developed world in the rate of maternal
mortality three times as deadly for
black women in the state of texas we
have got to win and we need you with us
and we need you now
this is what they're trying to say you
have to allow abortion up until and
including birth period which is what
codifying roey wade the way they want to
interpret it would do just to be clear
you have to do that
or women you will die
yeah
is anyone buying this honestly is anyone
buying this are even a liberal woman but
just just be like that woman with
gingersnap the shameful woman who said i
don't want to talk about that because i
want to kill whatever hasn't come
through my snook yet yeah
by the way i and i i mean this 100 right
now if you are a conservative republican
voting person right i almost sound like
i'm describing a person who has a womb
if you are a person who's going to vote
for republicans you had better mobilize
for this election do not sit idly by and
think that we've got to win because the
economy is doing poorly that's probably
going to help us
but if you are in a state right now
that has any chance of electing somebody
who's going to overturn this don't think
they stop with this it's guns it's this
it's every other right it's the ability
to speak freely on on the web because
we've seen that we can't even speak
freely here that's why we have mug club
right so we can actually say what we
want to say well today we're just taking
the risk they're taking the rights away
not us i'm saying today we're just
taking the risk here on youtube and
keeping it and by the way we love that
you guys are watching a mukbang of
course on humble but uh
also keep in mind
people say oh it's just the same two
sides of the same coin with donald trump
and hillary clinton you really think
this would have happened with hillary
clinton let's be clear about that yeah
and for people now who say oh they
rigged the election so there's no chance
you can't rig them that badly no get out
and vote now when it comes down to all
of the local elections
but keep in mind there are also judges
in your state you know that right
you know they have circuit courts you
guys know that right you know these
kinds of things happen all the time in
your state before they get kicked up to
the supreme court yeah
that's one of the problems we have with
the nra often they just sort of let
things go through the difficult cycle
and just sort of swoop in the last
minute and say oh
put my name on there like ben affleck
with a goodwill hunting script
yeah we did that he did it
all right we got that clip and then okay
so let me read the obama quote first
okay okay
oh i have an eric swalwell quote that
quote that's hilarious is it about a
chinese yeah you know he's convinced
chinese spies to get abortions there's
so many chinese babies that i would have
right now that's what i'm doing
i'm not even tried
you disgust me i did a poor trumps
there's nobody that would think that was
an actual truth your mediocrity rivals
amy klobuchar oh no she's number one
so he said uh barack obama said uh
today the supreme court not not not only
reversed nearly 50 years of precedent
it relegated the most intensely personal
decision someone can make to the whims
of politicians the most
intensely personal decision
someone can make
now let's go to former vice president
biden's speech
to choose
her right to make intensely personal
decisions with her doctor
free from the entertain from the
interference of politics
that's when he went off obama's script
yeah
obama's saying it into his ear
you should just walk up and just have a
an image of obama's tweets and say what
he said
i mean that's gonna be the talking point
now like that's oh it is all the
leftovers i cannot wait to watch the
sunday shows this week because you get
and i watch stuff that really pisses me
off because cnn is i mean we've just
we've exposed them for who they are
right right they're a mockery to news
but msnbc and the the guys at nbc chuck
todd still thinks that he's by god
actual news right he's come out and said
that this was the supreme court taking
away your rights yeah none of these
people seem to understand what a right
is it's not found anywhere in the
constitution that's right that they keep
pointing to because
justices who agree with them have said
the same thing and they've just ignored
it yeah so they have no idea what's
going on but they're going to actually
have panels of people lining up to say
how bad this country is i want to do
something here which i know could get us
in trouble but i want to do it anyway
okay
i mean i want you guys out there to find
picture by picture uh
the common act of performing an abortion
what it is
what happened in this country let's pick
a cartoon one you know one that isn't
real because that'll get us an animation
there's plenty of them because
it's relevant here so control room get
that for me particularly you know the
most common practice with the forceps
yeah there's probably i've seen that
around like 20 weeks or something like
that yep and because let me read eric
swalwell and uh
oh the irony train
it's not stopping here
he said extreme this is the guy who by
the way was having sex and revealing
secrets to chinese spies
extreme right-wing judges on the supreme
court just issued a death warrant
to women in america death warrant they
have decided that a piece of metal
designed to end life
is more valuable than the health and
safety of women in
america hold on a second
a piece of metal design and life
you talking about forceps there
sweetheart
more value than the health more valuable
than the health and safety of women in
america
1.6 million last year defensive uses of
firearms
two to three million on average and we
know that's an under count
a lot of them women
i think that's something to do with the
health and safety of women in america
because by the way we're not talking
about a third party we're talking about
a woman saving her own life
the face of an attacker so
a piece of metal designed to end life is
more valuable
the irony
you've determined that the piece of
metal designed to end life
is a constitutional right that and it
doesn't exist
it doesn't exist he's trying to save the
gun
it's not about importance
one is a right
let's just let's just separate this okay
let's just this is a piece this is a gun
perfect i was going to say my pencil i
was going to say let's use my pen we
have firearms i have a gun here let's
make sure that people know okay
all right everyone see okay no alec
baldwin all right
just to be clear okay
so
this is a piece of metal
all right
design and life
okay so let me read you his tweet one
more time and then i want to go to uh
hopefully we we have the infographics
there they've decided that a piece of
metal designed to end life is more
valuable than the health and safety of
women in america
a piece of metal design and life no it's
not design and life it's also designed
to save life
let's be clear about that
that's why it exists that's why swords
exist
so people learn how to fight
is everyone are we gonna condemn
everyone for scale it back takes martial
arts do we assume that they're all going
out to commit assaults now here's the
thing when he says health and safety
he's talking about abortion
right
it's an inanimate object
versus
a legally defined procedure
okay
a piece of metal designed to end life
here's a little experiment that i want
to do this is said piece of metal a gun
designed to end life is it possible for
there to be a scenario where this
inanimate object does not take innocent
life
and life walter ppks go
do it a second it's gonna get to it okay
okay
come on
all right so that inanimate object there
designed to end life
seems that it's not a requirement seems
that it doesn't end life
unless i go through a procedure
to take someone's life and by the way it
can end the life of someone who would
cause mass damage to other lives now he
says this piece of metal we just saw
most scenarios meaning nearly all it
doesn't end life then the health and
safety of women in america and he goes
on to substantiate this if you read his
subsequent tweets he's talking about
abortion
is there a scenario
in which abortion
doesn't end the life we've just
established this doesn't have to end a
life
is there any scenario in which the
process of abortion does not actually
end the life do we have the infographic
yeah yeah i sent one too just in case i
knew i knew somebody who had tweeted
let's bring let's bring this up this is
this is the most frequently performed
the health and safety technique and is
usually typically performed between five
and 13 weeks of pregnancy this would be
the earliest one ministering anesthesia
the abortionist uses a speculum like
this this speculum is placed inside the
vagina that a piece of metal then opened
specifically on the side allowing the
abortionist to see the cervix the
entrance to the uterus the cervix acts
as a gate that stays closed for the
duration of pregnancy protecting the
baby until it is ready for burns gotta
remove that protectionist uses a series
of metal rods
like these which increase in thickness
and diameter and the abortionist inserts
them into the cervix progressively to
dilate it gaining access to the inside
of the uterus where the baby resides
it's elaborate
heartbeat fingers arms and legs but its
bones are still weak and fragile
after the cervix is dilated
the abortionist will insert a suction
catheter similar to this
this is a plastic clear plastic
catheter firm
which has a hole
through which
the contents of the uterus are sucked
and
these contents are dragged down
and into either a syringe of this nature
so i think the point is made here
there's that hunk of metal
here's another hunk of metal by the way
tool man i think you have a hunk of
metal on you right now
i think everyone in this office
consistently does
has never ended a life
none of these firearms i gotta say
there's what there's probably
there's gotta be at least 15 firearms in
this office at any given moment at least
yeah probably more
call it 20
is a conservative estimate not one of
them has ever ended a life
there has never been a health and safety
procedure known as abortion
that has not ended a life
using hunks of metal yeah well unless it
was on accident yeah right like oh we
accidentally yeah we accidentally it
survived in which case ralph northam
governor ralph north and former governor
would say well then we would allow it to
be born and see what we want to do with
it afterwards yeah and i mean just so
you know watch if you watch the rest of
that video i'll just briefly tell you
what happens
that thing starts so this is 11 weeks
right let's say that you think oh okay i
didn't know like sometimes it takes
women a little bit of time to understand
that they're actually pregnant to take a
pregnancy test to see that they've
missed maybe wait a couple of weeks
after that i understand that this is 11
weeks this is probably a pretty
good approximation of
an early abortion right it's about as
early as you can get
maybe you can shave a few weeks off of
that
they turn the suction machine on
limbs start pulling off
of that body start being pulled in now
you can see this and again this is an
animation thank god
but you can see what's happening all
right let's show it let's show it sorry
guys i know some of you don't like this
but this is the reality if you haven't
seen it if you don't know and i i'm
always kind of amazed if people don't
know but again this is the most common
procedure because it's the procedure
that's necessary as early as possible
it's about as good as it gets it's about
as good as it gets right and that is
terrible to say all right let's show it
it has a force 10 to 20 times more
powerful
than the usual household vacuum cleaner
and using this technique the baby is
rapidly torn apart by the force of the
suction and squeezed through the tubing
down the suction tube into the syringe
or that's what you're trying to defend
at 11 weeks do it at 20
24
30.
35.
24 is massachusetts which we just talked
about
six months
six months i cannot
believe that we're not having an honest
conversation about this in this country
it's not a woman's right to choose they
can't have a conversation about it they
cannot have an once you have an honest
conversation about what the process is
about what abortion is
uh
the left loses
so that's why they have to obfuscate
that's why they have to say i don't want
to every single abortion activist who we
had gingersnap ass could not answer the
question yeah well i don't know and i
don't want to talk about that
i wonder why i wonder why the president
doesn't want to talk about it
elizabeth warren doesn't want to talk
about it i wonder why the vice president
doesn't want to talk about it i wonder
why the former president doesn't want to
talk about it wonder why hillary clinton
doesn't want to talk about it no one
none of them are willing to stake their
claim and say that's where we draw the
line
that's where we draw the line
none of them draw a line
and you want to say word extremists for
drawing a line anywhere
you draw a line nowhere
all this does today
and we can go to mug club briefly uh
here and take some chats so that uh i
couldn't know my club people like hey
what are we doing so um let's take the
chats on mug club because it'll probably
just get ugly on youtube anyway
all that happened today
is the supreme court who by the way
justices were appointed
by a democratically elected president
and by the way the most diverse supreme
court that's ever existed
more women and black people involved in
this decision than
roe v wade before
the supreme court just said hey
this is something that should be left up
to the local democracies
of the state
that's not how democracy dies
that's how democracy flourishes
that's how a constitutional republic
flourishes and not only that
it's just a step in the direction
i'll be honest my bias i think it should
go much further than this
it's just a step in the right direction
just even compared to europe
compared to every other country outside
of canada
that have far stricter abortion laws and
by the way they don't have republicans
they don't have conservatives
they have liberals and extra liberals in
europe but even on the issue of abortion
they look at what happens just in a
state like massachusetts with anyone
that's severe and they say come on
that's a little severe
all that this is not how democracy dies
it's how it flourishes it's how it's
protected it's the process we have that
has gone through many checks and
balances
it's also a step towards allowing our
humanity to return
this is how humanity flourishes
if nothing else comes from this
nothing else look everyone right now if
you're watching if you're listening on
audio
they are going to make this the issue
going into why because they think it's
their only potential winning issue
you see they even tried to brush past
the gun issue pretty quickly because
they know that doesn't bode well for
them
the economy doesn't bow well bode well
for them international policy doesn't
bode well for them they're thinking
well we can use the abortion thing
because
just as joe biden tried to say it's
extremist
right they just stripped you of your
rights because they think this is their
only chance
to set a narrative and lie to you and
the reason the reason they expect that
is because abortion is so ugly that even
the advocates for it
look away at the process
they don't really want to know what it
is
so
this is my call to action to you and
it's very very simple
what you need to do this is the only
issue that they think is their winning
issue
we've already won the economy issue you
can kind of do remedial right if you say
inflation get right before you they'll
go okay yeah i understand yeah it's been
pretty bad right the approval on the
economy is in the low 20s for this
former vice president give them remedial
on that
and then when it comes to abortion
your job is to educate them on the lie
that's all you need to do
what they think is their only winning
issue this election
you make their achilles heel
you do that by simply telling people the
truth you tell them what this law is
that states can do whatever they want
and you tell them what abortion actually
is
a fetal chart helps
sending them a link to something like
that video helps
that's your job
take their today this is not something
that unlike spineless republicans they
think it's a political liability
this can be turned into a tremendous
winning issue
that's what you do going forward
then there is no quarter
politically for them to win going into
november and you better vote
you better vote because i know it's not
perfect
underestimating your opponent is a
cardinal said overestimating them is
just as bad if you're saying that your
votes will all be wiped out and there
will be a blue wave well you know what
shame on you
vote and turn this one issue today this
historical landmark as i think amy
klobuchar said a day that will live in
infamy they're always trying to look for
some speech
booker this is like my uh i am spartacus
moment no it's your i'm a douche moment
just educate people this does not have
to be an issue we shy away from lean
right into it all right youtube we're
going to discuss this more
you can piss off
you